ORDER HI GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE I'M GONNA MAKE SEVERAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO EXPLAIN
OUR PROCESSES THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. ANDFOR ALL OF THOSE
FAMILIAR WITH THIS PROCESS WE
ARE GOING TO APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE WHILE I GO THROUGH IT
AGAIN FOR THOSE WHO MIGHT BE
TUNING IN FOR THE FIRST TIME.
SOMEONE TO COVER THE TECHNICAL
SIDE OF THINGS FOR TODAY. IN
RESPONSE TO THE CODE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC SENATORS AND SENATE
STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. SO
IN COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND
LOCAL ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND WE'VE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
HAS ACCESS TO OUR LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. FOR CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
ART AND WE HAVE TWO HEARING
ROOMS- TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY AS WELL. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
OUR PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER.
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE EIGHT THE
ACCESS CODE IS NINE EIGHT TWO
NINE TWO ZERO NINE. AND WILL
REPEAT THAT A COUPLE OF TIMES
THROUGHOUT THE MEETING. WHEN WE
DO MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY WILL OPEN YOUR
LAN. AND AT THAT TIME YOU MAY
ADDRESS A COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ANY
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE THAT YOU ARE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON. PRIOR TO GIVING
YOUR TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND SO WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND- WORKING WITH US
IN THAT REGARD. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE ARE HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. CUSTOMARY SEEMS SO
LONG AGO DOESN'T IT. I'M SORRY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS ADJUSTING TO THE
NEW ONLINE TOOL SO PLEASE BE
PATIENT SO THAT EVERYONE CAN BE
HEARD. AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
OUR COURT REPORTER. I'M GOING
TO ASK ALL SPEAKERS COLLEAGUES
AND WITNESSES ALIKE TO SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY AND IF WE
HAVE ANY TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES
I WILL STOP YOU. UNTIL WE
FIGURE IT OUT AND THEN. ALLOW
YOU TO CONTINUE SO FORGIVE ME
IT'S JUST THAT WE WANT TO BE
SURE AND GET EVERYTHING
RECORDED. SO BEFORE WE BEGIN
TODAY'S AGENDA WE WILL
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. AND A
REMINDER TO OUR COLLEAGUES
MEMBERS YOU'LL NEED TO TURN ON
YOUR MICROPHONES FOR THE ROLL
CALL AND EVERY TIME THAT WE
VOTE. SO WITH THAT ADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. GROWTH YOUR ROLE HERE
KAMLAGER HERE LONGER HERE
LAYARD NEAR THERE'D HERE FAITH
YEAH BATES HERE ATKINS HERE
ATKINS HERE THANK YOU AND NOT
JUST FOR THE PUBLIC'S BENEFIT
I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND NOTE
THAT- TWO OF OUR RULES
COMMITTEE MEMBER SERVE ON
ANOTHER COMMITTEE AT THE SAME
TIME AND SO THEY MAY END UP
HAVING TO COME AND GO AS
NECESSARY TO CONDUCT BUSINESS
SO I JUST WANT THE PUBLIC TO
KNOW WHY THAT IS- AND IN THE
EVENT THAT WE HAVE TO HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN. AT A CERTAIN POINT-
AND THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
DOING DOUBLE DUTY- I'M GOING TO
TRY AND GET- SOME OF OUR-
BUSINESS OUT OF THE WAY. SO
BEFORE WE GO TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO HEAR
GOOD TO BE HERE OUGHT TO APPEAR
SORRY. I'M GONNA SEE IF I CAN
GET A MOTION ON ITEM NUMBER TWO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR AND I'M
GOING TO DO IT LIKE THIS I'M
JUST GONNA TAKE IT. KIND OF ONE
CATEGORY AT A TIME SO THE
PUBLIC AND EVERYONE CAN FOLLOW
EASILY. I WOULD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON ITEM TWO- ITEM C. N.
THAT IS TO THE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL BOARD OUR
MOTION REMOVED. THANK YOU OUR
MAN SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL.
HELLO ALL RIGHT. FIVE KAMLAGER
I LONGER AYE LAYERED AYE. AYE
FAITH. AYE ATKINS HI I THINK
FIVE FIVE TWO THREE FIVE ZERO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR ITEM TO D.
R. MEMBER TO THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD A
MOTION OR MOVE. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL- HI.
I KAMLAGER I LONGER I LAYERED
ON AYE BATES. I CAN I CAN. FIVE
FIVE ZERO TWO R. F. FIVE MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA VETERANS
BOARD A MOTION OR WE DIDN'T DO
TO P. O. WE DIDN'T KNOW HOW
GALAXY I'M JUST MOVING RIGHT
ALONG- IN MY OWN MIND. I MOVED
TO WAY YOU WOULD MOVE TO A-
SENATOR. WELL LET ME ASK THIS
DO MY COLLEAGUES HAVE A PROBLEM
IF WE MOVED TO E. F. G. H. N.
I. AND THAT WOULD BE TO THE
PUBLIC OUR EMPLOYEES EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONS BOARD TO THE
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
APPEALS BOARD THE CALIFORNIA
VETERANS BOARD AND THEN WE HAVE
G. H. AND I COMMISSIONER FOR
THE BASE OF OZ SAN FRANCISCO WE
ACTUALLY JUST DID THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD SUED
B. E. ROOM I F. G. H. I.
SENATOR LAYERED THANK YOU SO
MUCH ON OUR YELL AT ME LATER
MAYBE I SHOULD ASK YOU TO SHARE
AND I CAN JUST ARE OKAY I'M
GONNA STOP DOING THAT THE- I
WILL MOVE THOSE ITEMS. THANK
YOU YEAH. THANK YOU HE THREW HI
THANK YOU SENATOR- I WILL
ACCEPT THAT MOTION. MADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL
THROW FIVE ZERO FIVE KAMLAGER
HI LONGER ARE YOU LAYERED HI
THERE I FAITH RIGHT IF I CAN
FIVE INSIDE HI I THANK MY
SENATORS FOR THE ASSIST AND
WITH THE LAST OUR MOTION IT
WOULD BE. FOR GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR MEMBERS OF THE WATER
COMMISSION AND IT WOULD BE ITEM
J. K. L. M. N. N. O. I WOULD SO
MOVE THANK YOU SENATOR FANFIC
OR TERRY WILL YOU CALL THE ROLL.
ROVE. NOTHING GROWTH NOT VOTING
MONGER I LONGER AYE LAYERED AYE
THERE'D I FAITH. IT'S 
VOTING AT. 1-057-532-0032 ZERO
I WOULD TO NOT VOTING AND THEN
THE LAST ITEM FOR TO DISPENSE
WITH WOULD BE ITEM NUMBER THREE
BILL REFERRALS. I WOULD MOVE
SOME THANK YOU SENATOR OUR
MOTION BY SENATOR LAYERED MADAM
SECRETARY I HAVE A QUESTION ONE
NIGHT SURE- I WONDER OF THIS IS
COME FROM R. CLASSIFIED STAFF.
THAT SO WE COULD NOT POSSIBLY
GET A COPY OF THE LIST THAT'S
BEING USED TO TRACK THE TWELVE
BILLS. THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS I
HAVE DESIGNATED NOT TO
DETERMINE THAT THERE TWELVE OR
FOURTEEN OR FIFTEEN BUT
SPECIFICALLY OUR STAFF HAS HAD
MORE DIFFICULTY WITH PROVIDING-
THE BACKGROUND ANALYSES FOR
SOME OF THESE BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT SURE WHAT'S COMING FORWARD
SO IF WE HAD A- LIST OF THOSE
THAT ARE COMING FORWARD. THEY
COULD START I HAVE HAD FOR ZOOM
CALLS TODAY WITH NO BACKGROUND
INFORMATION ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BILLS AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
PLAN WE'RE GETTING CALLS FROM
OUTSIDE THAT ONE OF SUPPORTER
OPPOSE THINGS THOUGHT. TO BE
JUST GOING ON SOMETHING LIKE
THAT THAT SIMPLE SO. IF THAT'S
POSSIBLE THAT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL. I AB AB. WILL TRY TO
MEET THE ARE REQUEST I'M NOT IF
THAT IS SAY. REFERRAL OF BILLS
THROUGH OUR PROCESS OR IT IS
THIS B. AND KEPT APPRISED OF.
HOW MANY. ASSEMBLY BILLS WE
HAVE THAT MEET THE- ON THE-
TRACK THE TWELVE BILL FOR. EACH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOUSE AND I
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT
TWELVE. IT'S ABOUT
UNDERSTANDING THAT THESE ARE
GOING TO BE YOU KNOW SENATOR
BATES. AB FIFTEEN FIFTY THEY
HAVE THEY ARE ABLE TO START THE
WORK ON THAT AHA. SO AND THEY
ARE ASSIGNED TO DIFFERENT
COMMITTEES SO WE'RE HAVING TO
TRAP IT HAS BECOME MORE
DIFFICULT. I THINK TO BE A
VISIBLE REQUEST AND IT'S NOT TO
BE LOOKED UPON AS TRYING TO.
DETERMINE WHO DOES AND DOESN'T
HAVE. WELL BILLS IT'S NOT ABOUT
THAT IT'S JUST HELP NO I UNDER
I UNDERSTAND I WANNA MAKE SURE
I GOT THERE. I GET TO STAFF THE
ADEQUATE REQUEST SO THAT WE GET
IT TO YOU- SO SORRY. SO THAT WE
SAID THAT WE GET YOU WHAT YOU
NEED BECAUSE WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
TRYING TO TRACK. YOU KNOW HOW.
YEAH THE ISSUE OF TWELVE BILLS
AND HOW. THEY'RE SET AND FOR
EVERY MEMBER. I OF THE ASSEMBLY
ALSO Mà. IT FOR OUR BILLS ALL
OF OUR BILLS GOING OVER. SO
ERIC I'M GOING TO ASK THE
SECRETARY OF THE SENATE TO WORK
WITH US. THE POLICY DIRECTOR IN
MY OFFICE TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
CLEAR ON WHAT'S BEING ASKED AND
THEY WERE ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE
THAT- AND MAKE SURE IT'S DONE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT ABSOLUTELY.
OUR MATTER BY SHARE. THERE WAS
A MOTION OKAY SO WITH THAT WHAT
AND UNDERSTANDING WERE MAKING A
REFERRAL TO MAKE SURE WE GET
WHAT IS REQUESTED- MADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL.
ROOFTOP ROOF I KAMLAGER I
LONGER I'D LAYERED ON THERE'D
AYE BATES AYE AYE ATKINS I CAN
FIVE FIVE ZERO WELL THANK YOU-
SO IF THERE ARE NO OBJECTIONS I
WILL TAKE UP OUR FIRST ON
TODAY'S AGENDA GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES ARE REQUIRED TO
APPEAR. LET'S SEE WHAT ITEM ONE
A. AND THAT WOULD BE- THE
APPOINTMENT OF TOMAS ARAGON DR
TOMASZ ERAGON STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER AND DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND DR THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
PATIENCE AS WE ARE GOT UNDER
WAY I WANNA- WELCOME YOU. AND
ASK YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE ANYONE WITH YOU OR
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE WILL TAKE THOSE
INTRODUCTIONS AND THEN MAKE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS YOU WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE. AND AFTER THAT I'LL GO
DIRECTLY TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS SO
WELCOME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
SOMEONE TO ACKNOWLEDGE- MY WIFE
I READ NEVER GONE THROUGH THIS-
WATCHING TODAY. I DO HAVE A
STATEMENT. WITH AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS I AM DOCTOR
TOMASZ UNDERGONE STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER AND DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. I WOULD FIRST
LIKE TO THANK GOVERNOR NEWSOM
FOR THIS INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY
I HAVE BEEN PROVIDED TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. IN
THIS MOST IMPORTANT TIME IN
PUBLIC HEALTH. I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND LEGISLATIVE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK IN THE
CONFIRMATION PROCESS. I AM
HONORED AND HUMBLED TO BE
BEFORE YOU TODAY. IT IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED TIME FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH AND FOR OUR COUNTRY. THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC REVEALED
AN AMPLIFIED SOCIAL GEOGRAPHIC
AND RACIAL ETHNIC DISPARITIES
AND EXPOSURES AND HEALTH
OUTCOMES THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES ACROSS OUR STATE. I
AM COMMITTED TO PROTECTING AND
IMPROVING THE HEALTH OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS BUT WITH MY
HIGHEST PRIORITY FOCUSED ON
ELIMINATING HEALTH INEQUITIES.
AS WE MOVE TOWARDS COVERED
RECOVERY I'M COMMITTED TO
ADDRESSING SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH IN ORDER TO IMPROVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES NVM AND THE
RESILIENCY OF OUR PEOPLE
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES. I
WILL LEAD AND MOBILIZED ACROSS
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY PAGE PROGRAMS
TO BETTER MEET THE NEEDS OF
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS. AND
THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE
PARTICULARLY ADDRESSING GROWING
PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS. ALSO TO
ALIGN THOSE PROGRAMS AROUND
SHARED PRIORITIES AND TO ENSURE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT'S WORK IS
TARGETED TO MEET THE CHALLENGES
OF THE STATE. I INTEND TO
FOSTER OPEN COMMUNICATION NOT
ONLY WITH A LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS BUT ALSO WITH
MANY STAKEHOLDERS TO REPRESENT
THE PEOPLE WE SERVE. I AM
COMMITTED TO OUR MISSION AND TO
THE HEALTH OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. DR THANK YOU SO MUCH-
SENATOR KAMLAGER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO GO AHEAD GO FIRST SINCE
YOU'RE ON THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
AND IN CASE YOU HAVE TO LEAVE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND IT'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN- DR ED
ARE GONE WE HAD A VERY- GOOD
DISCUSSION EARLIER TODAY AND- I
JUST ALSO WANT TO COMMEND YOU
FOR YOUR- COMMITMENT TO THE
SPACE OF PUBLIC HEALTH- ONE OF
THE THINGS. WE TALKED ABOUT
WAS- HOW PUBLIC HEALTH TENDS TO
FLY UNDER THE RADAR. WHEN YOU
SAID YOU KNOW WHEN NOTHING
HAPPENS OF COURSE NO ONE IS
TALKING ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THEN WHEN SOMETHING BAD
HAPPENS. THERE'S A LOT OF TALK
BUT THEN THEY'RE ALSO ALL OF
THE SORT OF CATEGORICAL FUNDING
REQUESTS THAT POP UP- IN YOUR-
THANKFUL FOR THAT BUT ALSO
WANTING US TO CONSIDER
INVESTING IN THE COURT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH SO. I WOULD LIKE
FOR YOU TO KIND OF EXPAND ON
THAT AND IF THERE WAS MORE
FLEXIBILITY WHICH WAS SOMETHING
THAT YOU MENTIONED. YOU KNOW
HOW DO YOU SEE YOUR ROLE IN
ENSURING- THAT OUR LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS- THAT YOU
WORK SO CLOSELY WITH- ARE ABLE
TO SERVE THEIR POPULATIONS
EQUALLY AND FAIRLY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THIS QUESTION.
THIS IS REALLY A SPECIAL HIGH
RIGHT NOW IN PUBLIC HEALTH ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES I'VE HAD OVER
THE YEARS IS TRYING TO GET
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
PUBLIC HEALTH IS. AND PUBLIC
HEALTH IS REALLY FOCUSING ON
BUILDING HEALTHY COMMUNITIES
AND ALL PRIMARY PREVENTION
WHICH IS WHICH TO ME IS THIS
WHERE I WANT TO PREVENT THINGS
FROM HAPPENING AND OF COURSE AS
YOU SAID NGUYEN FELT NOTHING
HAPPENS PEOPLE DON'T APPRECIATE
PUBLIC HEALTH WHICH IS GOING TO
BE CLEAN AIR SAFE WATER EXCEPT
ECCENTRIC. SO THE PANDEMIC
REALLY REVEALED HOW IMPORTANT
PUBLIC HEALTH AS PEOPLE
RECOGNIZE THAT WHEN YOU PREVENT
TRANSMISSION OF CULTIVATED. YOU
CAN PREVENT NOT JUST CASES
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATH BUT
YOU CAN PREVENT THE COLLAPSE OF
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM THAT
WOULD IMPACT SO MANY SO MANY
PEOPLE. FELT UNFORTUNATELY OVER
TO OVER TIME WHEN AFTER SELLS
DISASTERS HAVE HAPPENED THERE
IS AN INFUSION OF. CATEGORICAL
DOLLARS TO DEAL WITH THAT ISSUE
BUT OVER TIME THOSE CATEGORICAL
DOLLARS GO AWAY AND PUBLIC
HEALTH NEEDS IS ONGOING ONGOING
FUNDING COULD DEAL WITH THAT
CORE INFRASTRUCTURE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH THE CATEGORICAL DOLLARS
OFTENTIMES DON'T GIVE US THE
FLEXIBILITY TO BE ABLE TO PIVOT
AND TO DEAL WITH EMERGING
PUBLIC HEALTH PROBLEMS SO WE
NEED A CORE FUNCTIONAL
CAPABILITIES TO BE TO BE FUNDED
AND A CORE AREA IS GOING TO BE.
FOR EXAMPLE IS JUST AN
EMERGENCY PREPARED EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS- WE NEED TO TAKE A
MORE REGIONAL APPROACH TO WORK
MORE CLOSELY WITH THAT LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND REALLY
BALANCED THE NEEDS THEY DO WHAT
THEY DO WHAT THEY DO BEST WHICH
IS REALLY WORKING CLOSELY WITH
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND WE WORK
GOOD AT THE REGIONAL AT THE
STATE LEVEL USING ECONOMIES OF
SCALE TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE
LOCAL HEALTH. COULD BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THE OTHER MAJOR
AREA WHERE WE NEED- IMPROVEMENT
AND CORE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN THE AREA
OF BEHAVIORAL. HEALTH WE KNOW
THAT THE PANDEMIC. IS AND WILL
HAVE A LARGE MENTAL AND
BEHAVIOR HEALTH IMPACT
ESPECIALLY ON THE YOUNGEST IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT'S A PART
OF PUBLIC HEALTH FOCUSING ON
PREVENTION AGAIN WHERE WE
REALLY NEED TO IMPROVE OUR
CAPABILITIES. AND THE LAST AREA
THAT I WANT TO MENTION IT IS
GOING TO BE JUST IN OUR AREA OF
OUR LABORATORY CAPACITY. OUR
SURVEILLANCE UPDATING OUR IT
SYSTEMS WE ABSOLUTELY NEED TO
BECOME TWENTY FIRST CENTURY AND
IN TERMS OF OUR ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO. DELIVER PUBLIC HEALTH
SERVICES FOR FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA AND SO
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT I
WOULD I WOULD I WOULD FOCUS ON.
GREAT THANK YOU FOR THAT- YOU
WE ALSO ENDED UP. TALKING ABOUT
SEX AND DRUGS AND I DIDN'T
THINK WE WERE GONNA TALK ABOUT
THAT- IN PREPPING FOR THIS
MEETING BUT- THE WE TALKED
ABOUT THE INCREASE ACTUALLY IN
S. T. D.'S AND SEEING AN
EXPLOSION WITH SOME OF THOSE
NUMBERS- AS I MENTIONED AT
LEAST WITH HEPATITIS. AB I
BELIEVE IT IS- AT LEAST SEVEN
HUNDRED FOLKS WERE INFECTED IN
TWENTY ONE DIED FROM THAT VIRUS
IN LA YOU SEEN DIEGO AND IN
SANTA CRUZ AND AS- LUCK WOULD
HAVE IT- THREE OF THE MEMBERS
OF RULES. ACTUALLY REPRESENT
THOSE- AREAS SO YOU'VE GOT THAT
AND THEN YOU ALSO HAVE THIS
EXPLOSION. OF STD RATES FOR
SYPHILIS GONORRHEA AND
CHLAMYDIA- YOU KNOW WHEN I
ASKED YOU IF WE WERE READY FOR
THIS I MEAN DO WE HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE- AND THE
CAPACITY- TO DEAL WITH S. AND
THEN OF COURSE WE MOVED IN TO.
OPIOIDS AND THE IMPACT THAT
THAT IS ALSO HAVING SOMETIMES
ON THE SAME COMMUNITIES. SO
WANTED TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT THAT
IS TO JUST ASK YOU PUBLICLY.
HOW WE ARE GOING TO MANAGE THIS
EXPLOSION AND IF WE ARE READY.
SO THERE'S CERTAIN THERE'S
SEVERAL SEVERAL ISSUES THERE
THE FIRST ONE HAVING TO DO WITH
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED DISEASES
SO WE DON'T HAVE BEFORE THE
COVERED PANDEMIC THERE WAS A
LARGE INCREASE IN SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASES.
ESPECIALLY SYPHILIS GONORRHEA
CHLAMYDIA AND THEN CONGENITAL
SYPHILIS ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
WE'VE HAD NOW WITH KHALID. IS
THAT WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
DELIVER THE SUFFICIENT AMOUNT
OF SCREENING AND TREATMENT OF
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED DISEASES
AND IN FACT I WAS LOOKING AT
THE DATA TODAY. AND SOME OF THE
DATA SHOWS THAT THERE IS A
SLIGHT DECREASE AND I THINK
THAT'S BECAUSE WE DON'T. WE
HAVEN'T HAD SUFFICIENT TESTING
RIGHT NOW SO AS WE RECOVER FROM
COLD MAYBE REALLY HAVE TO GET
OUR SCREENING AND OUR TESTING
INFRASTRUCTURE BOB. YEAH OTHER
IMPORTANT AREA WITH SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASES IS AND
KANSEN VISITATION AND CONTACT
TRACING. AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
LOCALS HAVE LIMITED STAFF TO DO
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
LEARNED WITH CALLS MADE IS THAT
WE CAN REALLY SUPPORT- CASE
INVESTIGATION AND CONTACT
TRACING OUT A DISTANCE. USING A
MODERN SOFTWARE SO WE NOW HAVE
A VERY SOPHISTICATED DATA BASE
THAT ALLOWS US TO DO. CONTACT
TRACING FOR COPD PATIENTS THAT
SAME INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE'VE
NOW INVESTED CAN NOW BE USED TO
SUPPORT LOCALS. AROUND SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASES. SOME OF
THE SOME THE VERY FOR. ON THE
AREA OF DECEMBER. GONNA READ
AND COULD GENERAL'S. SOME OF
THESE ARE DO SEE THAT GO
UNTREATED OFTEN TEND TO BE
ASSOCIATED WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
ADDICTED TO DRUGS. WHO WHO WELL
I TRADE A SEX FOR DRUGS OR
OTHER RESOURCES. AND WHAT
HAPPENS IS THAT THEY DON'T GET
THEY DON'T GET DIAGNOSED THEY
DON'T GET TREATED AND THEN YOU
HAVE CASES OF CONGENITAL
SYPHILIS LAST HAS BEN
DECREASING. OVER TIME- WHAT WE
KNOW FROM THE DATA THAT'S BEEN
PRIMARILY ASSOCIATED WITH-
WOMEN WHO USE METHAMPHETAMINE.
BOB SO THE OPIOID OVER THE
OPIOID EPIDEMIC IS IT IS AN
ISSUE THAT IT'S A SORT OF A
SEPARATE TOPIC WHICH IS
CONNECTED. WITH ANOTHER ISSUE
THAT OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS HAS INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY AND RIGHT NOW
WITHOUT A FENTANYL AND
METHAMPHETAMINE AND POLY
SUBSTANCE USE. IT'S BEEN A- A
BIG ISSUE. AND I'M I'M HAPPY
TO. GOING TO MORE DETAIL BUT I
DON'T WANT TO TAKE TOO MUCH
TIME. NO NO IT SOME THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND- IT'S IT WAS
STARTLING FOR ME TO ACTUALLY
HEAR THAT WHEN YOU WHEN I TALK
TO BECAUSE I THINK IT REALLY
PUTS INTO PERSPECTIVE HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO HAVE A
SOLID. PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S REACHING-
THROUGHOUT EVERY DISTRICT AND
COMMUNITY- THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO MAKE SURE
FOLKS HAVE WHAT THEY NEED. I
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO TAKE UP
MUCH MORE TIME. FROM MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE QUESTIONS
BUT I DO KNOW THAT DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR- A REGULATING
MORE THAN TWELVE HUNDRED SNAPS
AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE ALSO FOCUS ON OUR- ELDERLY
POPULATION- THERE HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT IF WE WILL
HAVE A SNIFF SHORTAGE. THERE
ARE CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THE KIND OF TREATMENT
THAT OUR ELDERS ARE GETTING IN
THESE FACILITIES- AND SO WELL
YOU DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO
RESPOND- IT'S A SOMETHING OF
GREAT IMPORTANCE BECAUSE AS I'M
SO MANY OF US ARE THINKING
ABOUT OUR GRANDMOTHERS OR
GRANDFATHERS ARE FOLKS THAT WE
KNOW IN THE COMMUNITY WHO ARE
AGING. OR IN NEED OF- THESE
KINDS OF FACILITIES WE ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
A STATE THAT IS EQUALLY
INVESTED. IN MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAVE ENOUGH OF THEM AND THAT
THEY ARE FULLY OPERATIONAL AND
THAT THEY ARE PROVIDING THE
KIND OF CARE. THAT WE EXPECT-
SO YOU CAN CERTAINLY RESPOND IF
YOU WANT TO BUT I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THIS TIME. ALSO SINCE
YOU'RE SAYING WELL- JUST A VERY
QUICK COMMENTED THAT AND THIS
IS ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT WE USE DESCRIBING IS
A DEMOGRAPHIC SHIFT. WHERE WE
HAVE AN AGING POPULATION. SO
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING FOR
CALIFORNIA WAS JUST PUBLISHED
IN JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING IS
REALLY LEADING THE STATEWIDE
EFFORTS IN THAT AREA- AND THERE
IS. A BUDGET FROM THE MAY
REVISION THAT WAS JUST
PUBLISHED IN WILL MAKE SURE
THAT YOU WEEK WE SEND THAT OVER
TO YOU. BECAUSE INTO DETAIL
WHAT THE PROPOSALS ARE- FOR
THAT. THESE VERY AREAS THAT
YOU'RE DESCRIBING. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR A MAN BY
SHARE. THANK YOU A DOCTOR AGAIN
LET ME A JUMP ON WITH OF THE
COMPLIMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES REGARDING YOU
TAKING THIS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
POSITION IN AND SW ONE OF
THOSE FRONTLINE WARRIOR
POSITIONS AND WE KNOW THAT DODD
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICERS HAVE BEEN ON
THE FRONT LINES AND PROBABLY
HAVE HAD A LOT OF BLOW BACK ON
SOME OF THE DECISIONS THAT WERE
MADE UP. IN NEEDED TO BE MADE
IN AND NOW I'M IN A VERY QUICK
TURNAROUND AS WE THOUGHT
COALBED SWEEP THROUGH OUR
COMMUNITIES AND DO THE
DEVASTATION SO I THANK YOU FOR
BEING ONE OF THOSE WARRIORS AND
JUMPING INTO THIS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT POSITION AND NOW
CONGRATULATIONS FOR BEING
RECOGNIZED WITH YOUR RESUME FOR
BEING VERY QUALIFIED FOR THE
POSITION. I DO HAVE- I'D LIKE
TO FOLLOW UP VERY QUICKLY ON
SOMETHING BROUGHT UP ON THE
OPIOID THING I'VE BEEN WORKING
ON THAT IT SINCE- I. ACTUALLY
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY WITH
A DRUG CALLED ECSTASY I HAD TO
PAY A BILL ON THAT I DIDN'T GET
TOO FAR BECAUSE THERE IS SOME
CONCERN ABOUT CRIMINALIZING
DRUGS TOO OFTEN- SO I'D LIKE TO
HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
DECRIMINALIZATION OF DRUGS
THERE IS A POSITIVE SIDE TO
THAT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE BUT
THERE'S ANOTHER SIDE TO IT.
THAT OPENS UP A WHOLE WHAT I
CONSIDER TO BE A PANDORA'S BOX
OF IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
ENCOURAGING DRUG USE IN THE
PARTY SCENE AND THAT'S WHERE
WE'VE SEEN I THINK A LOT OF THE
UNFORTUNATE CONSEQUENCES OF FAN
MAIL GETTING LACED INTO
OPIOIDS- I KNOW I WAS A SOCIAL
WORKER DURING THE CON DR LEARY.
IN GENERATION AND I INTERVIEWED
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE AT THAT TIME
WHO WERE- INTO LSD AND
UNFORTUNATELY HAD A LOT OF
BRAIN DAMAGE BECAUSE OF THAT SO
I HAVE KIND OF MIXED EMOTIONS
ABOUT THE WHOLE THING AND WANT
TO BE. ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF THE
DECRIMINALIZATION ACROSS THEIR
RESEARCH. EVERY SPECTER OF
THEIR FEAR OF CONCERN TO ME-
ABOUT YOU FOR MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT QUESTIONS IS
A IMPORTANT QUESTION AND ALSO
TO ADDRESS SEVERAL DIFFERENT
ISSUES ONE ISSUE IS- FIRST OF
ALL I WANT TO START OFF WITH
FIRST JUST TALKING ABOUT USE
AND HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR US
TO PROTECT YOU IF. THE DEBT
DEVELOPING MIND OF USE IN
ADOLESCENCE WHEN IT GETS
EXPOSED TO REALLY ANYTHING
ANYTIME ANY TYPE OF DRUG THAT
CAN ALTER THE NEURAL CHEMISTRY
REALLY PROCESS O THE POTENTIAL
FOR USED TO BE ADDICTED TO
SUBSTANCES TO PROTECT OUR YOUTH
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT WHETHER
SOMETHING IS DECRIMINALIZED
LEGAL ILLEGAL IT DOESN'T
MATTER- SO FOR EXAMPLE WE DON'T
WANT KIDS SMOKING WE DON'T WANT
WE DON'T WANT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
ARE CONSUMING CONSUMING
CANNABIS THE SECOND ISSUE YOU
BROUGHT UP WITH THE ISSUE OF
YOU MENTIONED FENTANYL FENTANYL
HAS REALLY TRANSFORMED WHAT'S
HAPPENED AROUND OPIOID
ADDICTION- I WAS MENTIONING
EARLIER THAT YOU KNOW THERE ARE
NOW WHAT PEOPLE ARE DESCRIBING
AS FOUR WAVES OF THE OPIOID
EPIDEMIC WITH THE FIRST WAS A
PRESCRIPTION OF CHILD ARE
PRESCRIPTION OPIOIDS. AND WE
HAD HERE WHEN THEN WE HAVE
FOUND SMALL AND NOW WE'RE IN
THIS NEW PHASE WHERE WE HAVE
FENTANYL AND POLY SUBSTANCE USE
AND MAXINE AND ADULTERATION IT
IS BECAUSE IT'S BECOME SO
DANGEROUS AT ANY STREET DRAW
CAN BE CAN BE ADULTERATED WITH
FAT AND ALSO IT'S BECOMING
INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS FOR
ANYBODY TO BE. TO BE EXACT-
EXPERIMENTING WITH ANY TYPE OF
DRUG USE BECAUSE BECAUSE
PHANTOM OF THE OTHER BIG
CHALLENGING HALF WITH FENTANYL
IS THAT IT'S SYNTHETIC AND
THERE ARE OVER TWO HUNDRED
ANALOG IT'S INCREDIBLY CHEAP
HIGHLY ADDICTIVE AND VERY
DEADLY AND SO ON IT'S ALL AYE
AYE AYE DESCRIBED IT'S ALMOST
LIKE THE VARIANCE WITH KOBE.
NINETEEN IT'S FIGURED OUT HOW
TO REALLY. PENETRATE ARE
POPULAR AND I THINK THE LONG
TERM. YES REALLY GOING BACK AND
REALLY FOR. ON YOUTH WE REALLY
HAVE TO AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
DECREASE DEMAND. AND THEN YOU
MEANT MENTIONED THE ISSUE OF
DECRIMINALIZATION I THOUGHT
ABOUT THAT A THREE. THREE WAYS
ONE IS. ONE IS OF COURSE
DECRIMINALIZATION WHERE YOU
DON'T PUT PEOPLE IN PRISON
BECAUSE THEY ARE EXPERIMENTING
TO USE IN A TRIBE. THE OTHER
CATEGORIES LEGAL LEGALIZATION-
WE SAW CANNABIS WAS WE SAW
CANNABIS THAT WAS LEGALIZED SO
THAT YOU CAN PRODUCE YOU CAN
PRODUCE EIGHT EIGHT. TRUCK
THAT'S CAN BE CONSUMED MOSTLY
SAFETY BY ADULTS. BEYOND BEYOND
LEGALIZATION IS WHAT A PUBLIC
HEALTH WE CALL
COMMERCIALIZATION WHICH IS NOT
PROMOTING OF A DRIVE BASICALLY
FOR CONSUMPTION AND PROFITS.
AND IN PUBLIC HEALTH WE REALLY
TRY TO FOCUS ON WHAT IS GOING
TO WHAT IS GOING TO. REALLY I
HAVE CREATE THE LEAST HARM IS
GOING TO BE THE MOST HEALTH
PROTECTIVE. SO AND THAT'S
REALLY THE WAY THAT WE THINK
WITH THE WITH THE WAY THAT WE
THINK ABOUT IT REPRIEVE PUBLIC
HEALTH FOLKS IN GENERAL WILL
STICK WITH OUR SMALL SUPPORT
DECRIMINALIZATION. AND
LEGALIZATION WE BECOME
CONCERNED WITH SOMETHING
BECAUSE IT'S FOCUSED ON
COMMERCIALIZATION AND IS
PROMOTING A PRODUCT THAT HAS
BEEN ADDICTIVE POTENTIAL
ESPECIALLY WITH MAJOR TRACTIVE
TO USE- AND SO THAT'S WHERE WE
GET WE GET VERY COMES WE GET
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT I THINK
THAT'S PART OF WHAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING IN TERMS OF-
UNFORTUNATELY- PROMOTING. DRUG
USE. THAT EXPOSES PEOPLE TO
THAT RISK. THANK YOU FOR THE
LAW PHONE THOSE RESPONSES MAKE
IT DOES GIVE ME HOPE THAT WE
ARE LOOKING AT ANY IN A MULTI.
FACETED WAY BECAUSE THERE'S
THERE ARE CONCERNS THAT
UNDERLIE IT AND I THINK WHEN WE
WERE WHEN WE STARTED TO
ADVERTISE DRUGS FONG. THROUGH
THE MEDIA ON TV I MEAN- THERE'S
A DRUG FOR EVERY SINGLE LITTLE
THING YOU HAVE THAT EVERYONE OF
THOSE. HAS SOME HORRIBLE-
CONSEQUENCES AND IF WE START
PROMOTING BUT WHAT THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE MAYBE WE'RE
GOING TO SAY WEL I DON'T NEED
THAT YOU KNOW I'LL JUST TAKE AN
ASPIRIN TONIGHT OR WHATEVER.
BUT ANYWAY- ARE JUMPING TO
ANOTHER SUBJECT- REGARDING THE
MONITORING OF THE VARIANTS THAT
WE ARE NOW STARTING TO SEE POP
UP- HOW IS THE DEPARTMENT-
TAKING MONITORING THOSE IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND IT WHERE THERE
ARE VACCINES ARE. YOU KNOW
EFFECTIVE AGAINST THEM AND
WHETHER OR NOT WE WILL NEED
BOOSTER SHOTS IF WE HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED OF. THESE THINGS
MAYBE. GAIN TRACTION OR GAIN
STRENGTH. I. THAT GOOD COURSE
OF RIGHT NOW FORTUNATELY THE
BACK THAT HAVE BEEN APPROVED IN
THE IN THE UNITED STATES ARE
VERY EFFECTIVE AGAINST ITALIANS
IT IS IT'S IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE
TO COMPLETE THEIR SERIES. AREAS
THAT WERE MOST CONCERNED ABOUT
RIGHT NOW IS CALLED THE DELTA
VARIANTS. THAT WAS ORIGINALLY-
IDENTIFIED IN ENGLAND RIGHT NOW
IT'S ABOUT 6% AND ERA IN THE
I'M SORRY ABOUT THIS IT'S
ABOUT. 10% IN THE UNITED STATES
IN ABOUT 6% OF THE ICE LOOKS
RIGHT NOW IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THE DELTA VARIANT IS INCREDIBLY
INFECTIOUS MUCH MORE INFECTIOUS
STANDARDIZED IT- VERY AND THAT
WAS KINDA CAME OUT OF THE THAT
THE YOU CAN WHICH IS CALLED
THAT. THE ALPHA VARIANT WHICH
HAD TAKEN OVER PARTS OF THE
UNITED STATES BUT NOW WE SEE
THE DELTA VERY INCREASING AND
THERE'S SOME CONCERN THAT
ACTUALLY MAKE PEOPLE SICKER. SO
YES WE ARE VERY GOOD WE'RE VERY
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT- THE DELTA
VARIANCE AGAIN FORTUNATELY THE
VACCINES ARE VERY EFFECTIVE.
WE'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
CALIFORNIA- WE'RE NOW I'M MORE
THAN 70% OF THE POPULATION HAS
RECEIVED AT LEAST ONE DOES
WORK. WE'RE IN MUCH BETTER
SHAPE THAN MOST OTHER STATES
HOWEVER THERE ARE POCKETS OF
CALIFORNIA BUT WE STILL WANT IT
WE SAW A LOT MORE. PEOPLE TO
GET OUT. I VACCINATED. YEAH
THERE IS BROUGHT UP WAS THE
ISSUE. IT'S TOO SOON TO TELL
WE'RE GONNA REQUIRE BOOSTERS.
SOURCE CODE OF THE VIRUS. DOES
NOT MUTATE AS FREQUENTLY AS THE
INFLUENZA A VIRUS- AND IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT THIS THE VACCINE
WILL ACTUALLY GIVE US LONGER
LASTING PROTECTION WE DON'T
KNOW YET. WE'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE TO FOLLOW UP AND- TEST
PEOPLE TO SEE HOW LONG IMMUNITY
IS LASTING. BUT IF WE DO NEED A
BOOSTER IT'S UNLIKELY TO BE
LIKE INFLUENZA WE HAVE AN
ANNUAL BOOSTER TO PROBABLY BE A
LONGER PERIOD OF TIME. BUT
IT'LL TAKE IT'LL TAKE SOME TIME
TO REALLY SORT THAT OUT. THANK
YOU WOULD THAT MEAN THAT WHEN
YOU GET YOUR ANNUAL PHYSICAL
AND YOU GET A BLOOD TEST THIRDS
DETERMINING WHETHER YOU DO
HAVE. ANTIBODIES IN THEIR- IF
YOU'VE BEEN VACCINATED IS
ABOUT. YEAH SO YOU KNOW
HISTORICALLY. PEOPLE HAVE
LOOKED AT THE- ALL. BUT DOCTOR
YOU MIGHT IF YOU CAN HEAR ME
YOU MIGHT STOP FOR A MINUTE.
ALSO AND THEN WE HAVE HE SELLS
BETTER THAN T. CELLS THAT- THAT
PROVIDE WAS CALLED- CELLULAR
IMMUNITY AND IS ACTUALLY LONG
LASTING AND IS VERY EFFECTIVE
IN PREVENTING SEVERE DISEASE-
SO THAT'S REALLY THE IT'S
REALLY THE COMBINATION OF BOTH
CLOSE TO SO- ANTIBODIES WANE
OVER TIME TO GO DOWN. BUT THE
MODERN TECHNOLOGY CAN THAT
HAPPEN THAT CAN NOW LOOK AT T.
CELLS I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE
RESEARCHERS WILL BE LOKING AT
WILL BE LOOKING TO SEE WHETHER
WE HAVE. BOTH THE BODY AND
CELLULAR IMMUNITY ABOUT
SLAMBALL THAT LONG LASTING AND
IF THAT IS. AND THAT'S THAT'S
FANTASTIC NOW AFTER FLUID WELL
THANK YOU FOR THAT LISTEN IN
VIA APPRECIATED OUT SO I CAN
RESPOND TO. YOU KNOW SOME OF MY
CONSTITUENTS OF ON ON THE FULL
ISSUE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR SPONSORS AND AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS ON A WELL
DESERVED APPOINTMENT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR ARE
REALLY GOOD AND PRACTICAL
QUESTIONS I THINK. OF THE
SENATOR LIAR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MY CHAIR. THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME I BY. REALLY
APPRECIATED IT AND I THINK.
MAYBE I WOULD ASK A GLOBAL.
STRIKES ARE BECAUSE YOU OF.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE THE ONLY
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER AT THE
STATE LEVEL BUT GOT A MASTERS
IN PUBLIC HEALTH GOT AN EMPTY
AND GOT A PHD IN PUBLIC HEALTH
THE ANSWER FOR TEN YEARS AS A
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER AFTER
MANY YEARS IN. IT IS IN OUR
PUBLIC ROLES AND IN TALKING TO
YOU. YOU FOR SHOWED UP IN YOUR
CAREER IN SAN FRANCISCO AT THE
HEART OF THE HIV EPIDEMIC
BEFORE THE DRUG COCKTAIL WHERE.
SAN FRANCISCO GENERAL WAS
GROUND ZERO. AND THEN YOU GET
APPOINTED. YOU'RE YOU'RE IN THE
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER
POSITION WHEN THE PANDEMIC
BREAKS OUT. THEN YOU'RE POINTED
TO THE STATE POSITION IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PANDEMIC AT THE
TIME OF SURGE. AND THEN YOU
LIST AS ONE OF YOUR PRIORITIES
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS SO WHAT
DID YOU LEARN FROM THESE
DIFFERENT TOP- DRAMATIC
EXPERIENCES IN YOUR WORK
CAREER. THAT WOULD INFORM WHAT
DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD BE DOING
US A STATE OF EMERGENCY. UPPER
PEREGRINUS AGAINST ANY FUTURE
SUCH SITUATIONS- REALLY REALLY
GOOD QUESTION YEAH I THINK I
EVEN MENTIONED THAT I ALSO DID
I RAN A CDC TRAINING CENTER
RESEARCH CENTER AT UC BERKELEY
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH
FOCUSING ON INFECTIOUS DISEASE
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS I SPENT
ALMOST A YEAR IS JUST PREPARING
FOR THE PANDEMIC THAT. I THINK
YOU KNOW THAT NEVER THAT NEVER
CAME OF COURSE WE HAD EACH ONE
AND ONE- AND SO. WHAT AND SO
YOU KNOW I SPENT MANY YEARS
THINKING ABOUT THINKING ABOUT
HOW WE WOULD RESPOND TO
PANDEMIC AND IN FACT WE'VE
PULLED OUT ALL THOSE ARTICLES
IN THE CDC GUIDELINES. AND THE
FLAG ME TH CURVE AND SOCIAL
DISTANCING ALL THOSE THE TOOL
KIT WITH. WAS DEVELOPED BUT
HAVE NEVER REALLY BEEN. IN A
REAL CONCRETE WAY A LITTLE BIT
OF IT WAS IMPLEMENTED WITH SARS
WANTED EARLY EARLY TWO THOUSAND
AND TWO THOUSAND AND THREE- AND
SO. I WOULD SAY THAT WE JUST
LEARNED. ALL THE OPERATIONAL
DETAILS OF WHAT IT TAKES TO
ACTUALLY. ON TO COMBAT THE
PANDEMIC OF THIS SEVERITY. WE
JUST LEARNED A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT IN TERMS OF THAT
TESTING- THE IMPORTANCE TO DO
REALLY GOOD SERVICE GOOD
SURVEILLANCE EARLY DETECTION.
REALLY TRYING TO DETERMINE WHAT
THE DRIVERS OF THE INFECTION
ARE YOU CAN YOU CAN SEE THAT
FROM. THE BEGINNING FROM THE
BEGINNING HOW HOW LITTLE WE
KNEW ABOUT THE VIRUS WE ASSUME
THAT IT JUST SPREAD TO LARGE
DROPLETS WHEN IT WAS REALLY
SPREAD THROUGHOUT OUR SOULS AND
WAS AIRBORNE AND CAN TRAVEL
DISTANCES. WITH YOUNGER PEOPLE
WOULD ONLY HAVE SYMPTOMS WITH
ARMED FACTIONS WHEN WE COME TO
LEARN THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE ARE ARE A SIMPLE A
SYMPTOMATIC- IN SO ALL OF THESE
THINGS WORK- IT WORKED. REALLY
HOMEBUILDING HUMBLED EVERYBODY
AYE AYE I TELL PEOPLE ALL OF US
WERE WRONG AT SOME POINT ABOUT
COVERAGE. AND SO DID DID FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO REALLY. RESPOND
LEARN. PIVOT AND ADAPT. AND
EVENTUALLY BE SUCCESSFUL I
DON'T THINK THEY'RE REALLY
CONCERNED ME WHEN THIS STARTED.
YOU KNOW I STARTED GOING BACK
AND JUST LOOKING YOU KNOW THE
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN PANDEMIC IN
YOU'RE LOOKING. YEAR AFTER YEAR
WAVE AFTER WAVE AFTER WAVE AND
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE. A
VACCINE AS SOON AS WE DID. IT
IS HISTORIC AND SO WE'RE
INCREDIBLY FORTUNATE TO HAVE A
VACCINE. BOB RENO RIGHT NOW
IT'S A IT'S BEEN EIGHTEEN
MONTHS. AND IF WE DO NOT HAVE
THE VACCINE THIS WEEK. WE WOULD
NOT JUNE FIFTEENTH WHEN OUT OF
HER COURAGE. WE WOULD BE HAVING
ANOTHER CERTAIN WE WOULD BE
HAVING A SERVICE TO THE VACCINE
HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
YEAH I THINK THAT'S BEEN REALLY
USEFUL TO US IS LEARNING HOW TO
WORK MORE CLOSELY WITH THE
LOCALS. AND REALLY FIGURING OUT
THAT THE RIGHT BALANCE SO AT
THE STATE LEVEL WE HAVE
MATHEMATICAL MODELLERS DEVER
DOING PREDICTIVE ANALYTICS AND
HELPING US PROTECT THE NUMBER
OF CASES THE HOSPITALIZATION.
YOUR CAPACITY AND WE WHAT WE
WERE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH INTERVENTIONS WEEK
BEFORE. WE BEFORE THAT WHAT WE
PROJECTED WAS GOING TO HAPPEN
SO FOR EXAMPLE WE LIFTED. WHEN
WE LIVED IN A REGIONAL STAND
HOME ORDER AND- WE A LOT OF
STARTED OPENING UP THE ECONOMY
WE ACTUALLY DID THAT THROUGH
PREDICTIVE ANALYTICS WE WERE
ABLE TO OPEN UP TO. FOR WEEKS
EARLIER INSTEAD OF WAITING FOR
THINGS TO GO DOWN WE WERE ABLE
TO PROJECTED AND FEEL CONFIDENT
IN OUR OBJECTIONS TO BE ABLE
TO. TO BE ABLE TO MAKE BIG
POLICY DECISIONS LIKE THAT. AND
SO- THAT'S THAT'S TREMENDOUS-
YOU KNOW I CAN TELL YOU THAT
DID NOT EXIST TEN YEARS AGO SO-
AND I HOPE TO REALLY BUILD ON
THAT ON THAT EXCELLENCE. LOW
ARM. HE NIGHT SIR. THIS MORNING
WHEN ASK YOU ANYTHING I TO
ABOUT IT IN THE ZOO BUT THAT
RAISES A- THAT I. HAD I DIDN'T
YOU WHAT WHEN WE GET THROUGH
THIS IN SOME FASHION. WILL
THERE BE SOME FORMAL PROCESS
WITHIN YOUR DEPARTMENT OF A
POST MORTEM AND LOOK BACK AND
SAY THIS IS WHAT WE COULD HAVE
DONE BETTER THIS IS WHERE WE
MIGHT HAVE MADE A DECISION
DIFFERENTLY. OR INCLUDE THE
THINGS YOU JUST SAID WHICH SOME
OF THE INCREDIBLE THINGS THAT
WORKED WELL WILL THERE BE SOME
KIND OF PROCESS LIKE THAT- YES.
THERE THERE ALWAYS IS RIGHT NOW
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF DOING A
SMALLER- INTO FROM I WAS CALLED
THAT AFTER ACTION REPORT. AND
WE'RE WE'RE EVEN AYE YOU WOULD
WORRY VALUE WAITING HOW WE
MANAGE THE INCIDENT EARLY ON.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK AND
LOOK AT LOOK AT EVERYTHING
THERE IS THERE IS A H. A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT TO LEARN- AND IT WASN'T
IT WASN'T JUST THE FINANCE NOT
JUST A PUBLIC HEALTH
INTERVENTIONS. NOT JUST WORKING
WITH LOCALS. BUT PUBLIC HEALTH
INTERVENTIONS ARE ALWAYS VERY
DIFFICULT BECAUSE- WE WANT TO
DO THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ACTIVITY THAT GETS THE GETS THE
JOB DONE. AND UNFORTUNATELY
SOME IN THE MATTER. WHENEVER
YOU DO PUBLIC HEALTH
INTERVENTION- YOU'RE SOMEONE'S
ALWAYS GOING TO GET UPSET AND
SO. IT'S VERY VERY DIFFICULT
BECAUSE IT'S VERY CHALLENGING
BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE
HARM NOT JUST BY THE VIRUS BUT
THE SHUTDOWN. HAD HAD HAD A
REAL IMPACT. ON THE ECONOMY AND
PEOPLE AND SO- ALWAYS HAVE TO
BE VERY SENSITIVE AND BE
COMPASSIONATE AND UNDERSTAND.
THAT OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INTERVENTIONS- CAN BE DIFFICULT
CAN BE DIFFICULT ALTHOUGH WE
BELIEVE IF IT WAS THE RIGHT
THING. RIGHT THING TO DO. AND
THE ONE LAST QUESTION I KNOW
THAT. WHEN WE TALKED EARLIER
TODAY I MENTIONED THAT I HAD
RUN AND AIDS SERVICE AGENCY AT
THE HEIGHT OF THE EPIDEMIC. AND
WHEN I WAS RUNNING FOR THE
ASSEMBLY THE FIRST TIME I KEPT
MAKING THE STATEMENT IN PUBLIC
THAT I WANT TO GET ELECTED
BECAUSE I WANTED TO DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF FAITH STAFF TO
SIT. IN MY OFFICE. AND BE
POLITE TO ME. HEY IN. A REPORT
WAS TO. WANTED FINAL HAPPENED
IT TURNED TO BE FOR. BUT NOW
YOUR IN THAT POSITION. IF YOU
WERE A PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER.
FOR TEN YEARS SAID AND IN THE
DEPARTMENT BEFORE THAT. NOW YOU
ARE THIS THE STATE AND WE WERE
VOTED TO CONFIRM YOU AS THE
STATE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER.
WHAT DID YOU WISH THE STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER WOULD
HAVE DONE OR OR YOU WERE VERY
WORRIED THAT THEY WEREN'T
CONCERNED ABOUT ENOUGH WHEN YOU
WERE OF LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER TRYING TO INTERACT WITH
THE STATE. ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT IN GENERAL OR SPECIFIC
EVENT BACKYARD GO EITHER WAY IF
YOU COULD COME UP WITH
SOMETHING. YOU KNOW I THINK FOR
ME I FEEL IT- I HAD MENTIONED
THIS TO YOU EARLIER IN GENERAL
THE PUBLIC HEALTH COMMUNITY IS
VERY COLLABORATIVE. WE'RE NOT
COMPETITIVE- WE ABSOLUTELY NEED
TO SUPPORT EACH OTHER YOU KNOW
DISEASES. INFECTIOUS DISEASES
ARE EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS THEY
DON'T FOLLOW POLITICAL
BOUNDARIES REGION'S GET
AFFECTED YOU YOU HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER YOU DON'T CARE WHERE
THE WE DON'T CARE WHERE THE
BEST IDEAS COME FROM- AND SO
THAT AND THE CITIZENS. YOU KNOW
THE RESIDENTS OF THE STATE
EXPECT THAT THEY THEY DON'T
THEY DON'T WANT TO GO FROM ONE
TIMES NEXT THE NEXT COUNTY YOU
KNOW YOU DON'T CROSS COUNTY
LINE AND ALL THE SUDDEN THINGS
ARE VERY DIFFERENT. AND SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT WERE ABLE TO
COLLABORATE- AND ALIGN AND
COORDINATE AROUND PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES WERE GOING TO BE
MUCH MORE IMPACTFUL. AND SO IN
THE- WHAT. GIVEN THAT CONTEXT
MY EXPERIENCE WITH THIS WITH
THE STATE HEALTH DEPARTMENT
OVER THE OVER THE YEARS. HAS
ALWAYS BEEN INCREDIBLY
POSITIVE- WITH WITH THE STATE
WITH THE STATE HEALTH OFFICER
THE STATE EPIDEMIOLOGIST ALL
THE COMMUNICABLE DISEASE FOX- I
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH A LOT OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
THE ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH.
INVESTIGATIONS BRANCH OUR
RADIATION HEALTH FRENCH YOU
KNOW WITH THE NAVAL SHIPYARD IN
SAN FRANCISCO- JUST TREMENDOUS
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF SUPPORT
AND THE OTHER THING I MENTIONED
EARLIER IS THAT. OF THIS THE
STATE. ALWAYS TREATS THE LOG
NOT THIS IS BEEN MY EXPERIENCE
I'M NOT SPEAKING OUT FROM MY
EXPERIENCE WHEN I WAS LOCAL. IS
THAT THE STRAIGHT THE STATE
HEALTH DEPARTMENT ALWAYS
TREATED US WITH THE TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF RESPECT AS IF WE WERE
THEIR CUSTOMER. AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT AND THAT'S WHAT
I'VE NOTICED YOUR SINCE I'VE
GOTTEN HERE TO THE STATE HEALTH
DEPARTMENTIS THAT. THEY'RE
THEY'RE VERY ATTENTIVE TO THE
NEEDS- OF COURSE WE COULD
ALWAYS DO MORE WE CAN NEVER
THERE'S ALWAYS MORE THAN W CAN
DO BUT I REALLY LIKE THAT I
LIKE THAT. THE CUSTOMER CENTRIC
I THINK IT'S OF SERVICE TO THE
LOCALS. WELL THAT ISN'T THE
CASE WITH EVERY STATE
DEPARTMENT SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
EXPERIENCE IF YOU WANT TO
CONTINUE IT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR. BEING VERY RESPONSIVE
TO THE YOU'RE WELCOME. SENATOR
THANK YOU VERY THOUGHTFUL
QUESTIONS- SENATOR GROWTH.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM M. I
APOLOGIZE I IF I ASK YOU
DUPLICATE OF QUESTIONS BECAUSE
I BOUNCE BACK BETWEEN- HEALTH
AND RULES AT THE SAME TIME AS
SO PLEASE FORGIVE ME FOR THAT
AND I DO APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
BEING ABLE TO MEET WITH YOU-
PRIOR TO THIS. OPEN HEARING. I
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
REGARDING VALLEY FEVER IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN A
CALIFORNIA HAD THE HIGHEST
NUMBERS OF VALLEY FEVER IN THE
HIGHEST INCIDENCES ARE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY- DURING NINETEEN
AND TWENTY CDPH IMPLEMENTED A
MULTIMEDIA VALLEY FEVER
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN. AND CAN YOU
GIVE ME YOUR- ANY INFORMATION
OR SHARE WITH ME THE LESSONS
THAT WERE LEARNED FROM THAT
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN REGARDING
VALLEY FEVER. I YEAH SO THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR BRINGING UP
ON VALLEY FEVER I'M- I
UNFORTUNATELY I HAVE NOT HAD A
CHANCE TO REVIEW REVIEW THAT'S
ALL I DON'T HAVE A- IN THE
ANSWER FOR YOU AT THE MOMENT.
OKAY I DIDN'T MEAN TO ASK A
QUESTION THAT WE HADN'T TALKED
ABOUT AGAIN I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
BEING ABLE TO MEET. IT'S OKAY
IT'S OKAY IT'S A IT'S AN
APARTMENT IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT FONG FUNGAL
INFECTION. AND IT'S ANTICIPATED
THAT IN GENERAL I'M JUST STOP
SPEAKING TO YOU FROM JUST MY
KNOWLEDGE OF- THAT FUNGAL
INFECTIONS- BECAUSE BECAUSE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND INCREASING
HEAT AND DROUGHT. UNFORTUNATELY
I ANTICIPATE. THAT IT'S GOING
TO BE A BIGGER ISSUE FOR THE
SAME. OKAY THANK YOU SIR VERY
MUCH. AGAIN IF YOU'VE BEEN
ASKED THESE QUESTIONS- I DO
APOLOGIZE I KNOW THIS LIMPLY
EXPLANATION THAT I'M GONNA GIVE
IT FIRST BEFORE I GET DOWN TO
THE QUESTION- WILL BE LONG. AND
THEM IF YOU NEED ME TO STOP AND
WE CAN YOU KNOW DIALOGUE
BETWEEN- THIS SAID BE GREAT. I
WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT THE
FDA APPROVAL FOR VACCINES IN
THE U. EASY WAY. AUTHORIZATION
THAT WE'RE OPERATING UNDER NOW
FOR BECAUSE THE VACCINE THEIR
COPA NINETEEN- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I WANT TO TALK TO
YOU ABOUT. IS- PHYSICALLY- THE
UNDER- TWENTY ONE USC. CODE
THIRTY THREE SIXTY B. B. B.
THREE E. WHICH I'M SURE YOU'RE
AWARE OF BECAUSE IT DEALS WITH-
TO SEE- E. WAYS SPECIFICALLY.
AN INDIVIDUAL MUST BE INFORMED
OF THE OPTION TO ACCEPT OR
REFUSE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
PRODUCT OF THE CAR AND THE
CONSEQUENCES IF ANY. FOR
REFUSING ADMINISTRATION OF A
PRODUCT. AND OF THE
ALTERNATIVES TO THE PRODUCT IF
THEY'RE AVAILABLE. AND ITS
BENEFITS OR RISK ALTHOUGH NO
COURT THAT I KNOW OF HAS-
INTERPRETED THIS PROVISION.
BECAUSE THIS PROVISION HAS NOT
BEEN A LONG THERE'S NOT BEEN
CASE LAW ESTABLISH AN
ESTABLISHED. RIGHT AFTER NINE
ELEVEN. I MEAN THERE HASN'T
BEEN A- A CASE LAW THAT I'M
AWARE OF IF YOU ARE I'D LIKE TO
HEAR YOUR- INTERPRETATION OF
THAT- OF THE AND THAT. YOU KNOW
THE CASE LAW BUT- THAT
SPECIFICALLY FOR EMPLOYEES IT
SAYS THAT. THEY HAVE TO BE-
UNDER THE- E. WAY THEY HAVE TO
HAVE THE OPTION TO ACCEPT OR
REFUSE THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THE PRODUCT IN THE
CONSEQUENCES. OF REFUSING THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PRODUCT.
AND ALTERNATIVES FOR THE
PRODUCT IF THEY'RE AVAILABLE
AND ANY BENEFITS OR RISK. LIKE
I SAID I DON'T THINK A COURT
HAS RULED ON THIS BUT- IT'S MY
AND AGAIN I'M NOT A LAWYER
BARELY GRADUATED FROM HIGH
SCHOOL WENT TO A CONTINUATION
HIGH SCHOOL SO YOU KNOW IT'S
PRETTY ROTTEN KID- BUT BASED ON
MY INTERPRETATION THE FIRST
SEGMENT. OF THE SUB CLASS
SUGGESTS THAT- MANDATES ARE
CATEGORICALLY PROHIBITED- SINCE
EACH PERSON MUST HAVE THE
OPTION TO ACCEPT OR REFUSE. OF
WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT- SO
YOU'RE BRINGING UP A REALLY
GOOD QUESTION- SO IN GENERAL
WITH VACCINE WITH VACCINES- WE
BASICALLY HAVE THREE KEY
STRATEGIES- THE FIRST DREADED
USED TO RECOMMEND THE VACCINE
ANOTHER ANOTHER STRATEGIES TO
HAVE A VACCINE MANDATED IN
ANOTHER STRATEGY IS TO PROVIDE
INCENTIVES FOR PEOPLE TO BECOME
VACCINATED- THANK YOU MICHAEL
MANDATE IS NOT SOMETHING THAT A
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT OR
HEALTH OFFICER. WOULD IN
GENERAL WHICH WOULD DO IT'S
SOMETHING THAT REALLY WOULD IN
MY MIND- WE REALLY HAVE TO GO
THROUGH LEGISLATIVE PROCESS-
AND I WOULD NOT EXPECT THAT TO
EVEN BE AN ISSUE UNTIL IT
BECAME NOT FULLY STA APPROVED-
SOME TELL YOU I'M GIVING YOU MY
PERSPECTIVE AS A FROM FROM A
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND HEALTH
OFFICER PERSPECTIVE- IN GENERAL
WE WOULD NOT WE WOULD NOT
RESORT TO- MANDATING A VACCINE.
OKAY SO- TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT
ON THE KAISER FAMILY FOUNDATION
IT ACTUALLY SUPPORTS THE PUBLIC
HEALTH OR EXCUSE ME HEALTH
FAIRS ANALYSIS- OF THE LANGUAGE
THAT'S IN THAT CODE SECTION
BECAUSE WORRY IT YOU KNOW WE'RE
DEALING WITH THE EASY WAY
VERSUS A ACTUALLY FDA APPROVED
VACCINE WHEN IT COMES THE
COVERT VACCINE. AND- I GUESS
THE PROBLEM I HAVE IS THAT
THERE IS A GREAT NUMBER OF
EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE REQUIRING
EMPLOYEES TO BE VACCINATED IN
ORDER- WELL THEY DON'T REALLY
SAY IT SO THEY'RE VIOLATING THE
FIRST RULE BECAUSE THEY DON'T
PROVIDE THE EMPLOYEE WITH
OPTIONS OR THE CONSEQUENCES OF
REFUSING THE PRODUCT BUT UNDER
THE EMERGENCY YOU THOUGHT THE
AUTHORIZATION THE MANDATE-
CAN'T REALLY BE MANDATED
BECAUSE- IT'S NOT A FULLY FDA
APPROVED. VACCINES SO IS IT
YOUR OPINION THAT- BASED ON
JUST WHAT YOU JUST SAID. I MEAN
IS IT RIGHT OR WHAT'S YOUR
OPINION IF EMPLOYERS SAY YOU
KNOW YOU CAN NO LONGER BE
EMPLOYED HERE UNLESS YOU GET
THIS CODE THAT. YOU'RE ASKING A
VERY A VERY GOOD QUESTION AND I
HAVE NOT SPECIFICALLY- I DO WE
DO WAY THAT WE'VE BEEN FOCUSING
ON VACCINES IS- AND- IS TO
ENCOURAGE INCENTIVIZE. AS MANY
PEOPLE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE TO GET
VACCINATED AS A WAY TO FIGHT
THE PANDEMIC AND THAT'S BEEN
OUR PRODUCT AND THAT'S BEEN OUR
PRIMARY. APPROACH WE RECOGNIZE
SOMETHING AS SERIOUS AS
MANDATING MANDATING WE HAVE TO
BE SOMETHING THAT WOULD HAVE TO
BE DONE THROUGH A LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS IF IT WAS GOING TO COME
FROM GOVERNMENT. IN TERMS OF
THE PRIVATE SECTOR- I I'M I'M
NOT I'M NOT A LAWYER. I KNOW I
KNOW THE LAWYERS HAVE OPINED ON
THAT SPECIFIC ISSUE- AND SO I'M
NOT REALLY I DON'T FEEL
QUALIFIED TO STAY SAFE TO SAY
MORE- I KNOW THAT IT IS. MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT FROM THAT IT
IS LEGAL FOR EMPLOYERS TO DO
THAT AND I SUSPECT BILLS THAT
DO CHOOSE TO DO THAT WILL WAIT
UNTIL IT'S FULLY FTA APPROVED.
BUT THAT'S REALLY ALL I'M
PREPARED TO STAND AT THE MOMENT
OKAY I APPRECIATE THAT COMMENT
BECAUSE I DO I'M THERE YOU KNOW
I ANTICIPATE THIS WILL ALWAYS
SABRINA COURT AT. ONE POINT OR
THE OTHER I MEAN THAT'S JUST MY-
AND EDUCATED THOUGHT PROCESS.
BE I AGREE WITH STATEMENT I
DON'T THINK GOVERNMENT CAN
IMPOSE A VACCINE- ESPECIALLY
UNDER- THE ERC YOUTH
AUTHORIZATION CODE THAT
SPECIFICALLY SAYS THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO REFUSE IT BECAUSE IT'S
NOT FDA APPROVED. SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS ON
THAT- VERY MUCH- SO THE NEXT
QUESTION THAT I HAVE A GET OFF
OF THAT SCENES NOW BECAUSE I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES. AND FROM
ORANGE COUNTY COVERED. SOME
OTHER ISSUES ON VACCINES. I
HAVE SOME OTHER QUESTIONS AND-
HAVE YOU KNOW HAVE- I THINK ALL
OF US NOT JUST REPUBLICANS THE
DEMOCRATS AS WELL HAVE BEEN-
VERY CONCERNED AND ARE LOOKING
OUT LEGISLATIVE SOLUTIONS ON
MENTAL HEALTH- IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH EFFECTS OF THEPANDEMIC
ISOLATION DEPRESSION
ALCOHOLISM. THERE'S BEEN JUST A
LOT OF STUFF THAT HAS HAPPENED
OF BEING PENT UP FOR OVER A
YEAR. SO MY QUESTION TO YOU IS-
YOU KNOW GIVEN THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS THAT OUR SCHOOLS
WILL ULTIMATELY FACE AND I'M
AGAIN NOT A DOCTOR OR A LAWYER
BUT I JUST. LISTENING TO
PARENTS CALL MY OFFICE THEY'RE
DEALING WITH THINGS THAT THEY
HAVE NEVER HAD TO DEAL WITH
BEFORE HAVING THEIR CHILDREN-
ISOLATED FOR A YEAR AWAY FROM
THEIR FRIENDS AND OUTSIDE OF IN
PERSON LEARNING- WHAT'S THE
ROLE THAT YOU CDPH- HAS TO
COORDINATE EFFORTS WITH OTHER
DEPARTMENTS TO ADDRESS. AND
SPECIFICALLY YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES- IN THE STATE.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
TOPIC UP ITS FIRST FOR ME THIS
IS AN INCREDIBLY AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TOPIC IN. AND WE
STARTED RECOGNIZING THIS YOU
KNOW EARLY ON IN IN THE IN THE
PANDEMIC- YOU KNOW WHEN I WAS
HEALTH OFFICER IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND- WHATEVER WHATEVER. EARLY
AS GOALS WAS TO DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO GET KIDS BACK IN
SCHOOL. WE WENT OUT AND DID
SITE VISITS WE DID EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO GET THE SCHOOLS GET
THE SCHOOLS TO. OPEN UP THOSE
SCHOOLS WHERE THEY WERE THEY
WERE READY TO OPEN UP AND IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. THE OTHER
ISSUE THAT HAPPENS THIS IS JUST
THE STRESS THE LOSS OF THE LOSS
OF EMPLOYMENT IF YOU LIVE IF
YOU LIVE IN POVERTY OR YOU LOST
A JOB. THAT STRESS HAS AN
IMPACT ALSO ON THE NEURAL
DEVELOPMENT OF CHILDREN COOL
PEOPLE CALLED ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES ARE TOXIC STRESS.
SO WE KNOW THAT THOSE FAMILIES
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED THOSE KIDS
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED THAT'S NOT
JUST LEARNING LOSS IS ALSO THE
IMPACT ON THE RURAL
DEVELOPMENT. IN THAT'S GONNA
SHOW UP LATER IN TERMS OF
CHRONIC DISEASES BEHAVIORAL
PROBLEMS ISSUES WITH EXECUTIVE
FUNCTION AND- I REGULATING
REGULATING EMOTIONS. AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. ISSUE SO
FORTUNATELY IN THE GOVERNOR- IN
THE IN THE CURRENT BUDGET. DOES
HAVE A CROSS AGENCY OUR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIOR
HEALTH INITIATIVE. THAT'S GOING
TO FOCUS ON IN SEVERAL MAJOR
KERRY I'LL JUST MENTION THREE
OF THE MAJOR AREAS ONE AREA IS
GOING TO BE. ON DIAGNOSE SCENE
EARLY ON WITH PEDIATRICIANS
WERE TRAINED FOR TRAINED. TO
SCREEN FOR KIDS WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED ANY TYPE OF STRESS
SO THEY CAN START DEALING WITH
THOSE KIDS EARLY ON LIFE.
WORKING WITH SCHOOLS AROUND-
MENTAL HEALTH- TRAINING AND
TEACHING THEM ABOUT TRAUMA AND
HOW IT IMPACTS CHILDREN SO THAT
WE CAN GET THOSE CHILDREN INTO
MENTAL HEALTH CARE. BUILDING
BUILDING A STATEWIDE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SYSTEM THAT'S GOING TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF TELEHEALTH.
ANYONE IN THE STATE HAS ACCESS.
TO BE ABLE TO GET MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THAT IF THEY NEED TO.
AND THEN THAT THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT PA. IS GOING TO BE
SPENT. FOR ON THE CAMP. REYES
AWARENESS ABOUT HOW. HOW TO
RECOGNIZE IT HOW TO ACCESS
SERVICES. AND YOUR PER YOU'RE
BRINGING UP- AND INCREDIBLY
INCREDIBLY. IMPORTANT PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUE. AND THEN I THINK
ALL OF US REALLY HAVE TO COME
TOGETHER AND REALLY ADDRESS
BECAUSE- IF WE DON'T ADDRESS
IT- I THINK WE WILL SEE MORE
PROBLEMS DOWN THE LINE. THANK
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION. I A
I AGREE THAT IF WE DON'T
ADDRESS THAT WE WILL SEE MORE
PROBLEMS ONLINE AND THANK YOU-
I DID NOT KNOW THAT YOU WENT
OUT TO VISIT- SCHOOLS AND-
REALLY ADVOCATED FOR THEIR
OPENING I APPRECIATE THAT VERY
MUCH ESPECIALLY KEVIN- FROM
SOMEBODY OF YOUR STATURE. IN
YOUR POSITION IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE- DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO MAKE SURE OUR STUDENTS AND
OUR YOUNGER. GENERATION GET
THROUGH THIS CODE SITUATION AND
YOU BROUGHT UP SOMETHING THAT I
DIDN'T EVEN. ADDRESS IN MY
COMMENTS ABOUT YOU KNOW A
PARENT BEING UNEMPLOYED OR
LOSING THEIR JOB OR THEIR JOB
ACTUALLY BEING DEEMED
NONESSENTIAL. THEY WEREN'T
ALLOWED TO GO TO WORK EVEN
THOUGH THEY COULD HAVE GONE TO
WORK BUT THEY WERE ALLOWED TO
GO TO WORK. AND THAT HAS GOT TO
CREATE- STRESS IN A HOME
ENVIRONMENT. AND YOU KNOW WHAT
I LEARNED DURING THIS PANDEMIC
IS THEM. SOMETHING THAT REALLY
FRIGHTENED TO ME IS THAT YOU
KNOW SOME PLACES SOMETIMES AND-
SCHOOL IS THE SAFEST PLACE FOR
OUR CHILDREN TO BE. AND THAT IS
A REALLY SAD FACT THAT WE
LEARNED DURING THIS PANDEMIC- I
JUST WANT TO GO BACK TO A
PREVIOUS- QUESTIONS ON THE
VACCINE AND ONE OF STATE. FOR
THE RECORD IN CASE ANYBODY'S
LISTENING THAT. WOULD TO ATTACK
IN LATER. BASS ON MY QUESTION.
AND I AM NOT AN ANTI VAXXERS.
MISTER THE UNITED STATES
MILITARY BEEN DEPLOYED
OVERSEAS. I'VE BEEN GIVEN EVERY
VACCINE PROBABLY KNOWN TO MAN.
AND THAT HAVE SO I IT IS NOT
AND IT IS NOT ANTI VAX QUESTION
IT'S A PERSONAL FREEDOM
QUESTION. AND I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT GOVERNMENT OR ANY EMPLOYER
SHOULD MANDATE A VACCINE
EMPLOYEES OR TELL THEM THEY
CANNOT BE EMPLOYED THERE.
ANYMORE SO- I JUST WANNA
CLARIFY THAT IN SIR I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO TAKE ON
THIS A- POSITION AS MY-
COLLEAGUE FOR THE BAY AREA.
ALLUDED TO EARLIER. YOU WERE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. AND THEN RIGHT
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE DISASTERS
PANDEMIC YOU STEPPED UP INTO A
STATE WIDE LEVEL AND I
APPRECIATE- YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
TAKE ON THAT TASK. THANK YOU
SIR. YOU'RE WELCOME. THANK YOU
I DR- I APPRECIATE SO MUCH YOUR
BEING HERE TODAY AND I WANT TO
START WITH MY THANKS ARE. I'M
QUITE AWARE THAT AS AS WE AS AN
EMPLOYER AS THE SENATE AS AN
EMPLOYER- YOU TOOK THE TIME TO
MEET WITH OUR SECRETARY TO MAKE
SURE THAT QUESTIONS WERE
ANSWERED SO THAT WE WERE DOING
THE BEST JOB WE COULD AS AN
EMPLOYER- SO ON BEHALF OF. HER
AND CERTAINLY- HER COUNTERPART
IN THE ASSEMBLY I JUST WANNA
SAY THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO MEET DIRECTLY WITH THEM
TO HELP US- WELCOME. THE ARM.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD
BROUGHT UP AN ISSUE THAT YOU
SAID- IT REALLY HAVE
INFORMATION ON THAT RIGHT NOW
BUT YOU AT THE VALLEY FEVER
ISSUE. I'VE TALKED TO SEVERAL
OF MY COLLEAGUES CURRENT AND-
PAST OF WHO OF SERVE FROM FROM
THE AREA WHO BROUGHT THIS UP AS
AN ISSUE- I GUESS I WOULD ASK
THE COMMENT THAT YOU MADE IT'S
A BIGGER ISSUE- AT WHAT WE
SHOULD DO I WOULD ASK TO JUST
BE KEPT APPRISED OF THIS
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW IT. THIS
BECAME A REQUEST A IF IT BECAME
A DIFFERENT BUDGET REQUESTS
FROM A FORMER COLLEAGUE- FROM
TRACY AT ONE POINT FROM- YOUR
PREDECESSOR US SENATOR GROW
FROM BAKERSFIELD. AND AND I HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY WHEN I WAS IN
THE VALLEY TO MEET WITH SOME.
OF LOCAL FOLKS AND IT WAS
AMAZING TO ME THE NUMBER OF
FOLKS THAT BROUGHT THIS UP TO
ME PERSONALLY SO WHEN THERE IS
INFORMATION TO SHARE OR IF WE
NEED TO BE PROACTIVE. OUR AND
BE DOING SOMETHING DIFFERENT I
WOULD HOPE THAT WE COULD BE
MADE AWARE OF THAT BECAUSE IT
IS CONTINUE TO BE AN ISSUE SO
I'LL JUST. LEAVE THAT THERE-
BECAUSE WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
ISSUES OF. PAIRED FOR THIS
PANDEMIC OR- AND I APPRECIATE
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LA'S COMMENTS
ABOUT THE INFECTIOUS DISEASES
AND PARTICULARLY HEPATITIS A
AND THOSE ISSUES THAT WE HAD TO
DEAL WITH OUR COMMUNITIES WE
SHOULD'VE BEEN BETTER PREPARED
FOR THAT AND MAYBE THAT WAS OUR
LOCAL REACTION OR RESPONSE OR
WHAT WE SHOULD HAVE DONE THE
PIVOT. TO ADDRESS- AND I
APPRECIATE THE STATE STEP IN
AND HELP US WIN WHEN WE NEEDED
THAT BUT AS IT RELATES TO
VALLEY FEVER THE QUESTION I
WOULD SAY IS. AT WHAT POINT DO
WE NEED TO. YOU KNOW I'M NOT A
DOCTOR EITHER- MS GROW AS YOU
KNOW. BUT I JUST WANT TO KNOW
WHAT WE NEED TO BE DOING MORE
AND I COUNT ON YOU AS THE
EXPERT TO HELP US FIGURE OUT.
IF WE ARE NOT FOCUSED ENOUGH ON
THAT ON THAT ISSUE IN THAT
REGARD. TELL US WHAT WE NEED TO
BE DOING TO BE HELPFUL TO YOU.
FROM AND OTHER THAN THAT MY
COLLEAGUES ASK MOST OF THE
QUESTIONS. THE ONLY.
OUTSTANDING QUESTION I WOULD
ASK AS IT RELATES TO. OBVIOUSLY
THE PANDEMIC WERE IN BUT- THE
ISSUE OF DATA THAT HAS COME UP
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO IS TALKED ABOUT. DATA
AS IT RELATES TO THE L. G. B.
T. Q. COMMUNITY AND AS THIS
PANDEMIC GOT UNDER WAY. YOU
KNOW I DON'T KNOW IF WE WERE.
YOU WE HAD TO PAY THAT WE HAD
TO DO A LOT AT ONE TIME AND
THAT'S ALWAYS IN THE MIDDLE OF
A CRISIS. I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
FEEL ABOUT THE DATA WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO COLLECTED MORE WE
QUICK TO- TO RESPOND IN IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE WERE AWARE
OF SO WE GET THE DATA AND WE
SEE. THE NUMBERS RELATED TO THE
LATINO THE- A. P. I. X. AFTER
EXCEPT FOR ALL OF THE
COMMUNITIES AND- HOW IT IMPACTS
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES- THE
DESPERATE I KIND OF. RESPONSES
AND REACTIONS- I'M JUST LIKE
YOU TO COMMENT GENERALLY ON
DATA COLLECTION. AND ARE WE
ABLE TO BACK UP AND GET ANY
INFORMATION THAT WE WEREN'T
GETTING THAT ALSO INCLUDES THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY BECAUSE- YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU'RE LEFT OUT OF
THE DATA COLLECTION. IT'S
PROBLEMATIC AS WE'VE SEEN
HISTORICALLY WOMEN WERE LEFT
OUT OF DATA COLLECTION AND
STUDIES AND THINGS THAT COULD
HELP US BE. BETTER TREATED. AND
THAT'S TRUE FOR SO MANY
COMMUNITIES AND WE THOUGHT WE
WOULD BE FURTHER AHEAD ON. ON
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY IN
COLLECTING DATA THERE AND IT
TURNS OUT WE WEREN'T I DON'T
THINK. SO WE YOU JST COMMENT
ON ON THE DATA PIECE AND
WHETHER WE CAN BACK UP AND-
CORRECT. YES THANK YOU SO MUCH
IT IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
QUESTION SO. IN TWENTY ELEVEN
WHEN I BECAME TO HELP OFFICERS
SAN FRANCISCO ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS WE DID WAS. WE BROUGHT
TOGETHER A TEAM- INCLUDING
STAKEHOLDERS AND WE DEVELOPED
BY ACTUALLY ONE OF THE FIRST.
GUIDELINES PROBABLY IN THE
COUNTRY I KNOW CERTAINLY THE
STATE AT THAT TIME. GUIDELINES
ON COLLECTING INFORMATION ABOUT
RACE ETHNICITY SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND GENDER IDENTITY
AND SOMETHING WE GIVE ALL THREE
SEPARATE GUIDELINES THAT REALLY
BECAME THE BASIS. OF WHAT OTHER
FOLKS CAN'T IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. AND AND IT IT- IT
REQUIRED FOR US TO DO IT
CORRECTLY REALLY REQUIRED US BY
WORKING WITH THE DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE GOT IT RIGHT. WE TRY TO
FIGURE OUT EXACTLY HOW TO ASK
THE QUESTIONS. AND THE NFL TIME
IT WAS REALLY PRIMARILY
DIRECTED AROUND HEALTHCARE
SERVICES HEALTHCARE SERVICES.
IS SO LITTLE DIFFERENCE I MEAN
BECAUSE YOU HAVE ELECTRONIC
MEDICAL RECORDS YOUR PROVIDER.
AS THE SYSTEM. IS A LITTLE BIT
EASIER SET SET UP. WITH
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES
COMMUTABLE DISEASES AS WELL BUT-
SO WE HAVE A SERVER. SYSTEM
WHERE HEALTH SYSTEMS FOR
LABORATORIES. PROVIDE US THE
DATA. AND OFTENTIMES THE DATA
THAT COMES IS VERY LIMITED SELF
A LOT OF THE LAB SLIP IS
POSITIVE OFTENTIMES IT DOESN'T
HAVE ALL THE INFORMATION THAT
WE WOULD WANT ON THAT SPECIFIC
CASE. AS TO WHETHER CHALLENGES
WE HAD WITH FACT BECAUSE IT IS
THAT IF THE INFORMATION WASN'T
COLLECTED BY THE PROVIDER OR
WASN'T- USUALLY THE LABS ARE
NOT GOING TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION IN ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION. AND THEN WE SAID
WITH THEIR SIGHTS SET UP ALL
ACROSS THE STATE TO TEST AS
MANY PEOPLE I NEED A TESTING.
SO IS SPECIALLY EARLY ON AND WE
DID WE DID NOT EVEN HAVE A GOOD
RACE ETHNICITY DATA IT WAS VERY
BAD. AND IT TOOK IT TOOK A
WHILE TO GET THE IMPROVE THOSE
SYSTEMS UP. THE GENDER IDENTITY
DATA DID EVENTUALLY IMPROVED A
ONE OF THE BIG GAP AREAS
CONTINUES TO BE SEXUAL
ORIENTATION. AND THAT ALSO
CONTINUE TO BE TRUE ALSO FOR
VACCINATIONS THE FOR
VACCINATIONS YOU CAN GET
INFORMATION ON GENDER IDENTITY.
BOB I'M NOT SEXUAL ORIENTATION
SO THESE ARE CAP AREAS THAT WE
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO FIX. BOB AND
I AND I AGREE I AGREE WITH YOU-
IF WE DON'T IF WE DON'T MEASURE
THAT WE'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE. I ISSUES AND IT'S A
VERY IT'S AN INEQUITY THAT. WE
NEED TO WE NEED TO ELIMINATE.
WELL THANK YOU DOC HOPEFUL YOU
CAN. WORK WITH US IN HELP A- ON
THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT WE
DON'T TRY TO MAKE. LIFE
DIFFICULT ALTHOUGH SOME MIGHT
DISAGREE. WAIT WHILE WE DON'T
NECESSARILY TRY WE JUST PUT IT
THROUGH OUR LANDS OF WHAT'S
IMPORTANT IN MAKING SURE THAT
YOU UNDERSTAND OUR CONCERN- SO.
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR-
COMMENTS QUITE YOU KNOW TO US
IN DIALOGUE I REALLY
APPRECIATED. WE ARE GOING IF
NOTHING. FURTHER WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
RIGHT NOW THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK. AND WE'RE GONNA START
ART RIGHT HERE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE. AND IT WILL BE
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK FIRST IN
SUPPORT. R. AND SO I WILL-
REMIND WITNESSES TO ENSURE
SOCIAL DISTANCING DON'T FORM A
LINE ONLY ONE PERSON AT A TIME
AT THE MICROPHONE. ONCE A
WITNESS CONCLUDES THE NEXT
WITNESS MAY COME FORWARD TO THE
MICROPHONE. SO LET ME ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE. HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF DR
ERA GOD. OKAY SEEING NO ONE
APPROACH THE DYESS IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE WE HAVE
ANOTHER ROOM I'M GONNA LOOK AT
MY SCREEN AND SEE IF ANYONE IS
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. I DO NOT
SEE ANYONE OUT WAITING IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE SO THIS IS THE POINT
WHERE- WE WILL TURN TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
AND SO LET ME WELCOME OUR
MODERATOR WHO'S BEEN STANDING
BY AND ASK IF YOU WOULD PROP
THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU ARE
COMMON IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. BACK COMMAND
AGAIN ONE SEVEN ZERO. MR LINE
TWENTY FOUR YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN AND MISTER MODERATOR ONE
SECOND LET ME- BEFORE TWENTY
FOUR GOES AHEAD LET ME SAY. TO
THE WITNESSES WE ARE GOING TO
ASK THAT WHEN YOU SPEAK PLEASE
PROVIDE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION IF ANY. AND THE
POSITION ON THE APPOINTMENT WE
ARE STARTING WITH SUPPORT. AND
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF OUR COURT
REPORTER PLEASE SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY AND WITH THAT
MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE GO
AHEAD I'M SORRY. TO INTERRUPT
YOU. ALTHOUGH IT IT'S OKAY OF
LINE TWENTY FOUR YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. BLIND. TWENTY FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT DAY CAME
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LINE. GO AHEAD AND SEVENTEEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CONNIE TELL COTTO ON
BEHALF OF THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORUM IN SUPPORT OF
DR ERICA THANK YOU. WHY
THIRTEEN. THE MEDICARE MEMBERS
CAST YOU BURKE WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZING THE TRUE
SERVANT LEADERSHIP OF DR ED ARE
GOING IN SUPPORT. BLIND TWENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU MADAM PROTON
THE MEMBERS AND ASKING I WOULD
KEEP YOU PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF THE NURSE FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP WE ARE AN EARLY
MATERNAL AND CHILDHOOD PUBLIC
HEALTH INTERVENTION THAT
CONNECTS NURSES TO FIRST TIME
ON COMPASSIONATE PEOPLE IN WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF DR
IDAHOANS NOMINATION BEFORE
CONTAMINANTS WORLD IN SAN
FRANCISCO WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE HIS APPROACH TO
EQUITY AND ENSURING DIVERSITY
TO MOST VULNERABLE AT THE CORE
OF OUR PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE.
SIXTEEN GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
PROTON AND MEMBERS REBEKAH
MARKETS REPRESENTING LEADING H.
CALIFORNIA SPEAKING AND STRONG
SUPPORT AT DR OREGON DEPARTMENT
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE. TWENTY THREE. AFTERNOON
CHAMBERS MITCHELL GIVEN THE
COUNTY HOPE THE BACKING OF THE
DICTATION OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THE LOCAL
DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE HERE TENTH THE COURT
DOCTOR ARE GONE COMPANIES AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING A
DOCTOR ARE GOING ON AND MANY
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES THAT STILL
NEED TO BE ATTRACTED OUR STATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE LINE.
TO FOURTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MARIA WEBER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA-HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR
ARE GONE IN FACT. ALL OF THEM
AND LEADERS DURING THE CALL AT
NINETEEN AND THEN I WILL BE
CRITICAL I THINK WORK
COLLECTIVELY TO RECOVER AND
BASICALLY PUBLIC HEALTH RIGHT.
EIGHT ZERO. THANK YOU. END OF
MADAM CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'LL BE BACK
WITH YOU IN JUST A MOMENT SO I
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM THE
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION AND IT WILL BEGIN
WITH- ANYONE HERE ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE I HAVE NOT SEEN
ANYONE ENTER. OR APPROACH. SO I
WILL AGAIN LOOK AT ROOM ONE
TWELVE ALSO SEEING NO ONE-
PRESENT THERE. MISTER MODERATOR
WE'RE BACK WITH YOU FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT MIGHT WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION GO RIGHT
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR COMMENT IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN
ZERO. AND I SHOW NO COMMENTS
COMING THROUGH AT THE TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR HELP OKAY I
WILL COME BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND ASK FOR A
MOTION. I THINK THE VICE CHAIR
BEAT YOU TO IT PRIOR. THE
MANAGER I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT YES PLEASE I JUST LIKE
TO SAY I THINK THIS IS AN
EXEMPLARY APPOINTMENT TONIGHT
REALLY SHOWED IN IT IN OUR
DISCUSSION AND I THINK WE
SHOULD CONFIRM HIM BEFORE HE
CHANGES HIS MIND- THIS IS A- WE
SHOULD ALL BE LUCKY FOR HIS
WILLINGNESS TO SERVE. AND I
THINK THE QUICK MOVE AND MOTION
BY OUR VICE CHAIR WAS EVIDENT
OF THOSE COMMENTS SO- I SEE
SHAKING HEADS AND OFF. ON
DOCTOR ERAGON WE I CAN TELL YOU
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN BECAUSE OUR GOOD
SENATOR FROM BAKERSFIELD HAD TO
GO BACK TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE- BUT WITH THAT. I
WILL ASK MADAM SECRETARY TO
CALL THE ROLL. GROVE KAMLAGER I
AM LONGER I'D LAYERED HI THERE
I BATES HI IT'S AYE ATKINS AYE
ATKINS AYE. IT IS FOUR TWO ZERO
BUT WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN SO WHEN SENATOR
GROWTH COMES BACK OUT LET US
EXTEND OUR CONGRATULATIONS TO
YOU DR ERIC ON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. LET ME SEE IF
WE NEED TO ACTUALLY- WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THAT WE JUST MADE I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE
ROLE ALL DOCTOR GONNA STILL
WITH US AND ASK IF YOU'RE
PREPARED AND READY TO GO
THERE'S A MOTION TO MOVE THE
CONFIRMATION. GROWTH RIGHT
GROWTH I. FOR YOU TAKE OFF
THAT'S A FIVE ZERO-
CONFIRMATION WE WILL MOVE IT TO
THE FLOOR AND AGAIN WITH OUR
THANKS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU DO
WE NEED TO TAKE A FIVE MINUTE
BREAK YES WE WILL TAKE A FIVE
MINUTE BREAK BREAK WE'LL BE
RIGHT BACK THANK YOU.
I'LL TELL
ITEM ONE B. UNDER GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR.
AND THAT WOULD BE THE
APPOINTMENT OF DARCY L. HOUK
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. COMMISSIONER
WELCOME AND LET ME JUST SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I ALSO INVITE YOU TO
INTRODUCE ANYONE EAT WITH YOU
OR THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE- AND THEN MAKE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS THAT YOU'D
LIKE TO MAKE IT AFTER THAT WILL
GO DIRECTLY TO MY- COLLEAGUES
ON THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS SO
WELCOME. THANK YOU- GOOD
AFTERNOON HONORABLE CHAIR VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR CONSIDERING MY APPOINTMENTS
TODAY AND THANK YOU TO THE
MEMBERS AND THEIR STAFF FOR
THEIR TIME DURING THIS CALL
NATION PROCESS. I'M HONORED AND
HUMBLED TO BE HERE TODAY I WANT
TO- SPECIFICALLY THANK GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM FOR ENTRUSTING ME
WITH THIS IMPORTANT POSITION I
WANT TO RECOGNIZE AND THANK MY
FAMILY FOR THEIR SUPPORT OVER
THE YEARS THAT HAS ALLOWED ME
TO TAKE ON THIS ROLE. I ALSO
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF MENTORSHIP I WAS
LUCKY TO HAVE- SEVERAL MENTORS
WHILE I WAS. YOUNGER IN
PARTICULAR I WANTED TO
RECOGNIZE THE LATE STAR HAD
JUST AND- PROFESSOR MILLER
MURPHY IN KEVIN JOHNSON AND
PROFESSOR ARTURO GHANDOUR AT UC
DAVIS. ALL OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
OFFERED A MODEL OF EXCELLENCE
WHILE PROVIDING STUDENT SUPPORT
GUIDANCE AND OPPORTUNITIES TO
SUCCEED. I FULLY UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE WILL BE CHALLENGES
AND DIFFICULT DECISIONS TO MAKE
AS IF YOU SEE COMMISSION ARE
THIS INCLUDES DECISIONS ABOUT
ELECTRICITY RELIABILITY
IMPLEMENTATION OF POLICIES TO
ELIMINATE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE.
ADDRESSING THE COST OF WATER
SERVICE DURING EXTREME DROUGHT
CONDITIONS. THESE DECISIONS
WILL REQUIRE BALANCING MANY
BEATING INTEREST. I HAVE SPENT
OVER TWO DECADES WORKING IN THE
ENERGY NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER SECTOR REPRESENTING STATE
AGENCIES TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS AND
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. I'VE
SERVED AS AN ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGE AT THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION AND AS
CHIEF COUNSEL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION.
THESE EXPERIENCES COMBINED WITH
MY COMMITMENT TO INCLUSION AND
EQUITY I BELIEVE WILL SERVE
CALIFORNIA WELL I HOPE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE PUC'S EFFORTS
AND PROVIDING COMMUNITIES
BETTER ACCESS TO OUR PROCESSES
AND EXPANDING AFFECTED
COLLABORATION WITH OUR SISTER
AGENCIES. I UNDERSTAND THAT
MANY OF THE DECISIONS THAT YOU
SEE WILL NEED TO MAKE IN THE
NEXT FEW YEARS WILL HAVE
IMPACTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA. IT
IS THEREFORE IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE INCLUSIVE TRANSPARENT
PROCESSES THAT ALLOW FOR
MEANINGFUL PARTICIPATION BY
DIVERSE STAKEHOLDERS AND ENSURE
THAT INFORMED DECISIONS ARE
MADE IN. AN EQUITABLE MANNER.
IN MY ROLE AS A COMMISSIONER I
COMMIT TO WORK TOWARDS ENSURING
INCLUSION FOR CALIFORNIA.
PARTICULARLY TRIBAL RULE AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHO
ARE ALL TOO OFTEN OUT OF OUR
PROCESSES. I ALSO COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH MY FELLOW
COMMISSIONERS AND SISTER
AGENCIES TO ABOUT TO DEVELOP
POSITIVE INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS
TO MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS
EXPAND BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
AND WORK TO ENSURE ARE
REGULATED ENTITIES PROVIDE
RELIABLE STATE PORTABLE.
SERVICES TO ALL OF CALIFORNIA
SO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF MY
APPOINTMENTS AND I'M AVAILABLE
FOR ASK YOUR QUESTION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND CENTER
LAYERED I AM GOING TO START
WITH THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR IN. OUR I
APPRECIATED THE CHANCE TO MEET
TOGETHER AND JUST SHOULD SAY.
FOR SOME REASON AND THIS MAY BE
TRUE WITH EVERY MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE I JUST HAVE SO MANY
DISTRICT ISSUES THAT INTERACT
WITH YOU AND- THE
DECOMMISSIONING OF DOWNLOAD
DIABLO CANYON THE- OF THE
FOURTEEN THOUSAND ACRES P.
JEANNIE HAS THAT WE WOULD LIKE
FOR PERMANENT LAND CONSERVATION
THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE A
SPECIAL. ROLE IN REGULATING
WATER ON THE MONTEREY
PENINSULA. AND YOU ALSO HAVE A
ROLE IN VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
IN THE SANTA CRUZ MOUNTAINS
WHICH IS A THERMONUCLEAR ISSUE
A BIT SO. AND SO JUST FOR THE
RECORD WE TALKED ABOUT ALL
THOSE THINGS AND ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THEM. NOW I HAD A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS IN THE FIRST ONE.
IS MORE GLOBAL BOOK ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT EXISTS HAS EXISTED
FOR THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AS THE CULTURE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND IT. YOU KNOW
WE TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT A
DEAL WAS WRITTEN ON A NAPKIN IN
A FOREIGN COUNTRY AND THAT
THERE ARE LOTS OF ISSUES AND
THAT. THE PEOPLE THAT PRECEDED
YOU IMMEDIATELY WERE APPOINTED
TO ADDRESS THIS IS THIS ISN'T
JUST YOU IT FITS PEOPLE COMING
IN BEHIND. WHAT'S YOUR VIEW OF
YOUR ROLE. OF THE SORT OF
DEALING WITH THE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND THE CULTURE. AT THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. THANK YOU
SENATOR PER THAT QUESTION. MY
ROLE IS- I AM SURE IT IS
SOMETHING THAT STARTS WITH THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE ORGANIZATION
SO AS A LEADER IN THIS
ORGANIZATION I NEED TO LEAD BY
EXAMPLE AND NOT LEADING WITH
TECH READY IT MEANS- WORKING
WITH MY FELLOW COMMISSIONERS
WHO I THINK MADE IT- VERY
POSITIVE SHIPS AND THE WORK
THAT THEY HAVE DONE WHICH CAN
BE SEEN FROM. SEVERAL EXAMPLES
INCLUDING- LOOKING AT OUR OUR
DECENTRALIZATION EFFORTS TO
HAVE MORE OF A PRESENCE AND
BOTH- SACRAMENTO AND IN LOS
ANGELES- HAVING- MORE
STREAMLINED ENFORCEMENT
PROCESSES I THINK ONE OF THE
EXAMPLES IS OUT OF THE PG&E
BANKRUPTCY WE HAVE AN AND-
HAMSTEAD FORCE MEANT PROCESS
THAT ULTIMATELY IF THE UTILITY
DOESN'T HI WITH BILL- LEAD TO
IT IT ISSOLVING AND I DON'T
THINK ANY OTHER PUBLIC
UTILITIES GEN. THREE THOUSAND
THAT KIND OF ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS I THINK WE'VE ALSO MADE
CHANGES REGARDING- OUR
CONFIDENTIALITY- TOOLS AND
REGARDS TO WHO BEARS THE BURDEN
OF SHOWING WHAT. WHAT CAN BE BY
UNDER AND REALLY PUBLIC. AND
WE'VE MADE CHANGES TO OUR RULES
OF PRACTICE AND PROCEDURE- THAT
ARE ALSO CONSISTENT WITH
LEGISLATIVE. FORTY THREE ON
TAXES SOME OF. THOSE BE
EXAMPLES- AND I THINK THAT- MY
FELLOW COMMISSIONERS HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES AND I HOPE
TO CONTINUE ALONG THAT PATH AND
REINFORCE THOSE CHANGES AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE OPERATING
IN A TRANSPARENCY- MANNER.
GREAT AND I THINK IT EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE JUST SPENT A
BRIEF AMOUNT OF TIME ON THAT
THAT IS PROBABLY ONE OF THE
MOST PARAMOUNT THINGS ABOUT
YOUR SERVICE. AND YOUR
APPOINTMENT SO IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO HEAR THAT
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE THAT.
THAT CHANGE IS NOT
ACCOUNTABILITY. I THINK THERE
ARE PLENTY OF THINGS TO ASK
ABOUT MAYBE THE OTHER ONE I
WANT TO AND WE TALKED ABOUT IT
IT'S IN OUR MEETING YESTERDAY.
IS ELEVEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS
NOW OR WITH COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATION THEY HAVE. LOOK FOR
WAYS TO DO RENEWABLE ENERGY AS
PART OF THE PORTFOLIO AND
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATION
HAS HAD A MIXED REVIEW AT THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION I
KNOW I HAPPEN TO REPRESENT ONE
OF THE STRONGEST ONES THAT GOES
FROM SANTA CRUZ TO SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY. AND OFFERS
RATES THAT ARE LOWER THAN THE
COMPETING RATES OF THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES. WHAT'S YOUR VIEW
ABOUT COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATION AND HOW IT FITS%
INTO THE SCHEME THAT YOU WILL
DEAL WITH THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. THE COMMUNITY
CHOICE AGGREGATION HAS
INCREASED RAPIDLY IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS AND I THINK THAT- IT
CHANGES THE DYNAMIC AND HOW THE
UC REGULATES AND WE ARE WORKING
THROUGH- THOSE DYNAMICS SO IT
IT DOES CREATE CHANGES TO HOW
WE REGULATE I THINK A COMMUNITY
CHOICE AGGREGATORS ALSO CAN
PROVIDE. ADVANTAGES BY
REPRESENTING THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THEY'RE SMALLER SO
THEY- HAVE SOME ADVANTAGES IN
BEING ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE TARGETED TO
SERVE THEIR CUSTOMERS IN WAYS
THAT MAKE IT A LARGER LARGER
UTILITIES MAY HAVE MORE
DIFFICULTIES WITH- BUT AGAIN IF
IT DOES CHANGE THE WAY WE DO
THINGS SO I THINK IT'S- GONNA
REQUIRE. BALANCING THE INTEREST
OF ALL OF OUR CUSTOMERS MAKING
SURE THAT THAT COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATE CUSTOMERS ARE ABLE TO
HAVE FAIR AFFORDABLE REASONABLE
RATES WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
BALANCING THE ISSUE OF.
ENSURING THAT SOME OF OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
MAY NOT BE PART OF IT YOU
CHOICE AGGREGATE ARE- BEARING
THE BURDEN OF ADDITIONAL COST-
SO IT WILL BE A BALANCING ACT
BUT- AND I THAT SOME. THERE'S A
LOT OF PROMISE AND LOOK AT HOW
WE FORWARD BUT WITH THIS NEW-
SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT ARE THAT
ARE STEPPING UP. THANK YOU AND
I THINK YOU'VE HEARD THE
CONCERN FROM HERE ABOUT IT TO
JUST REMEMBER THAT CONCERN IS
OUT THERE IN THE BALANCING
THERE IS A REAL DESIRE TO MAKE
SURE THAT IS TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT- LEAVE IT AT THAT WHAT
THE OTHER- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ASPEN APPRECIATE YOUR-
WILLINGNESS TO SERVE AND THANKS
FOR BEING RESPONSIVE TO MY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SENATOR
MEADOW VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU I
AM AN- SHE ATE OF THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAD TO
HAVE. OUR I CALL IT IN PERSON
IT WAS IN THE ZOOM MEETING
YESTERDAY AND I APPRECIATED-
THE CONVERSATION AND YOU HIT ON
THE TOPICS THE MOST THOUGHTS
CERTAINLY MOST CONCERN TO ME
PERSONALLY BUT TO MY DISTRICT
AND I'M SURE OFF ALL OF- ARE
CAN ALL OF OUR- COLLEAGUES
DISTRICTS BECAUSE IT IT TOUCHES
US ALL IN. YOU SAID THEY WERE
YOUR TOP PRIORITY CERTAINLY
ISSUE ARE BEGIN THIS YEAR AND
WHEN IS THE **** ENERGY
METERING AND I THINK THAT KIND.
TALK ABOUT IN TERMS OF
BALANCING AND THE FACT THAT TO
OUR- THE WEALTHIER HOUSEHOLDS
ARE REALLY HAVE AN ADVANTAGE
OVER OUR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
IN TERMS OF THE NET ENERGY
METERING NET INNER G. METERING
ESPECIALLY AND I AM WONDERING
AND WE HAD A CONVERSATION ABOUT
IT USE THE TERM BALANCE. BUT I
THINK I'D LIKE SOMETHING THAT'S
A LITTLE MORE SPECIFIC IF
YOU'RE YOU'RE AT THAT POINT IN
THE YEAR DISCUSSION WITH YOUR
YOUR COLLEAGUES ON THE BOARD-
ARE YOU DEVELOPING ANY CRITERIA
BY WHICH YOU CAN EVALUATE.
POTENTIAL CHANGES TO THE
PROGRAM ARE STILL THAT YOU'RE
MOVING TOWARDS BALANCING IT
WILL BE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT I
BELIEVE BECAUSE THOSE WHO ARE
BENEFITING BY- THE CURRENT
PROGRAM. WITH THE- THE SOLAR
ENERGY TO THE HOMES OF ARE
GOING TO AT SOME POINT BE
IMPACTED AS THEY YOU KNOW THE
PROMISES MADE THEY WILL FEEL
WE'RE NOT CAP TO BECAUSE THEY
WERE ARE INCENTIVIZED TO DO
THAT BY THE FACT THAT THEY ARE
GETTING CREDIT RATHER THAN
MAKING A LARGE PAYMENT BUT
OBVIOUSLY THE OTHER COMPONENTS
OF. ENERGY DELIVERY TO THEIR
HOMES AND BUSINESSES ARE
CLEARLY REQUIRED MORE
INVESTMENT HE ON THE GRID AND
ALL THE TRANSMISSION ALL THAT
SO WE'RE HOPING AT THIS POINT
TIME WE'RE GOING TO SEE
SOMETHING COMING THAT'S NOT
JUST PROCESS DISCUSS BUT ACTUAL
PROGRAM DISCUSSED OF WHAT
POTENTIAL CHANGES YOU MIGHT BE
CONSIDERING OFF FOR. THEIR.
AUTO PROGRAM IN PARTICULAR.
THANK YOU SENATOR YES WE
CURRENTLY HAVE AN OPEN
PROCEEDING OFTEN REFER TO IS
NOW THREE POINT OH- WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF PARTIES AND NOT
PROCEEDING THAT HAVE- VARYING
PERSPECTIVES ON HOW WE SHOULD
PROCEED REGARDING- OUR NAME
DECISION THERE IS A ROBUST
RECORD BEING DEVELOPED RIGHT
NOW THERE'S GOING TO BE A
NUMBER OF WORKSHOPS- THERE'S
GOING TO BE TESTIMONY TAKE AND
BRIEFING ON THE ISSUE. IT IS AN
OPEN PROCEEDING SO I DON'T WANT
TO PREJUDGE ANY DECISIONS THAT
MAY BE COMING OUT I AM
FOLLOWING IT CLOSELY IT IS A
VERY IMPORTANT SEATING THAT IS
A PRIORITY TO THE COMMISSION
AND WE DO ANTICIPATE THAT THERE
WILL BE A DECISION COMING OUT
LATER THIS YEAR- EARLY NEXT
YEAR. AND- AND WE'RE WE ARE
DEFINITELY LOOKING AT- WHAT THE
CURRENT SITUATION. IS AND-
TAKING ACCOUNT OF ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT WE'RE GETTING
TO IN ORDER TO PROVIDE A FAIR.
DECISION I AM HAPPY TO TALK TO
OUR- GA DIRECTOR AND WE CAN
PROVIDE YOU SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON NOT PROCEEDING
AND WHERE WE ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF- MAKING THOSE DECISIONS BUT
WE DO ANTICIPATE A DECISION
BEING ISSUED SOMETIME AYE AYE
AGAIN IT BY THE END OF THIS
YEAR OR VERY. WE'LL TAKE IT OUT
THAT CERTAINLY ARE COMFORTING
TO HEAR- HOPEFULLY IT'LL BE IN
FRONT OF LEGISLATION THAT'S-
CURRENTLY IN THE HOPPER THAT
WOULD DO IT LEGISLATIVELY THERE
ARE PERHAPS BEFORE YOU'RE
COMING OUT WITH. YOUR CRITERIA
AND SOME PRIORITIZATION OF YOU
MAY HAVE TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION BECAUSE AGAIN THE
BALANCE. BECOMES EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO BOTH SIDES OF THE
ISSUE ARE CLEARLY AND IT'S
ALWAYS IMPORTANT SHOW THAT OUR
PUBLIC KNOWS. THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE BEFORE THEM AND
THEY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
WEIGH IN. ON THE IMPACT THAT
THEY SEE BOTH POSITIVE AND
NEGATIVE GOING FORWARD SO THERE
IS A BALANCE AND- EVERYBODY'S
GONNA SHARE. IN THE BENEFITS
AND CERTAINLY A LITTLE BIT OF
THE BURDENS IF THAT'S GOING TO
BE THE DECISION. ARE YOU ALSO
SET A TOP PRIORITY WAS
BROADBAND ARE NOT GOING TO GET
INTO THAT DEEPLY- I KNOW SOME
OF THE OTHER ON COLLEAGUES HERE
WILL WANT TO ASK ABOUT THAT.
BUT OUR DISCUSSION WAS ABOUT
THE- COMMENT THAT'S BEEN MADE
OF- QUITE A NUMBER OF TIMES BY
FELLOW OF SENATE COLLEAGUE
REGARDING THE FACT THAT WE
PUTTING A LOT OF MONEY INTO. A
DIGITAL DIVIDE ISSUES SUB THE
MIDDLE THE MIDDLE MAN AND I
THINK IT'S CALLED. THAT WE
DON'T SEE ANY ON ANY PROJECTS
YET AND I A LOT OF IT IS GOING
TO. THE NON PROFITS BUT HOW
WITHOUT YOU KNOW GETTING US TO.
ACTUALLY DEVELOPING THAT TERM
THAT VERY NECESSARY MIDDLE AS
PART OF. YOU KNOW THE DELIVERY
OF NUMBER OF FASTER AND BROADER
AND ACTUALLY HAVING A BROAD
BEYOND SO I JUST PUT THAT OUT
THERE FOR YOU TO GIVE A BRIEF.
THAW RESPONSE ACTUALLY ON A
WHAT WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT AND
I DID IN OUR OUR MEETING ASK
YOU IF YOU HAVE ANY SPECIFICS.
THAT YOU COULD PROVIDE TERMS OF
HOW YOU'RE APPROACHING THAT IN
TERMS OF THE MONEY LOTS OF
MONEY LOTS OF MONEY OVER
SEVERAL YEARS THAT'S GONE INTO
THEIR PHONE I THINK THE BUDGET
NOW SHOWS ABOUT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS. WHERE THE PROJECTS
ARE. DO WE HAVE SOMETHING YOU
KNOW READ. SOMETHING TANGIBLE
THAT WE'RE TAUGHT OKAY AT THIS
POINT IN TIME. THANK YOU
SENATOR YES WE HAVE- CEMEX MAP
ON WHERE INFRASTRUCTURE AND-
WILL NEED TO GO CURRENTLY- THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED AYE I
THINK AS YOU SAID A SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR INFRASTRUCTURE-
EXPANSION IN BROADBAND AND-
FOUR MILLION OF THAT- WE'LL BE
LOOKING AT STUFF- GOING TO WHAT
WAS REFERRED TO AS THE MIDDLE
MILE WHICH CAN'T WAIT TO-
SOMETHING I CAN TO TRANSMISSION
LINES FOR ELECTRIC SYSTEMS THAT
WILL BASICALLY BE. ABLE TO-
PROVIDE EXTENSIONS- AND FILL
GAPS IN AREAS THAT ARE EITHER
UNDERSERVED OR UNSERVED AND
THEN ANOTHER THREE BILLION
LOOKING AT WHAT'S REFERRED TO
AS LAST MILE WHICH IS- THE
ACTUAL CONNECTION. THAT MINDSET
THAT CONNECTS THE CUSTOMERS TO.
THE SYSTEM AND- WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS- CREATING THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE IN A WAY THAT
PROVIDES OPEN ACCESS WHICH
WOULD ALLOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TRIBES AND OTHER ENTITIES TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THE SYSTEM AT A
REASONABLE RATE RIGHT NOW-
WE'RE MISSING INFRASTRUCTURE
WHICH IS CREATED GAPS AND THE
SERVICE AND WE ALSO HAVE-
PROVIDERS THAT ARE OPERATING
SYSTEMS THAT. ARE EITHER
CONGESTED FOR THERE'S
DIFFICULTY IN ACCESSING IT
BECAUSE IT'S NOT AN OPEN ACCESS
SYSTEM SO WHAT WE'RE HOPING TO
DO IS- BE ABLE TO. ASSIST WITH
OTHER AGENCIES TO BE ABLE TO
GET THIS FUNDING OUT THEIR BILL
THESE GAPS AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE OPEN ACCESS
SERVICE TO- CALIFORNIA
CUSTOMERS I THINK OVER THIS
LAST YEAR WITH THE PANDEMIC
WE'VE SEEN A CRITICAL NEED. FOR
ALL OF CALIFORNIA TO BE SERVED
BY BROADBAND- FOR EDUCATIONAL
PURPOSES WORK RELATED PURPOSES
AND- TELEMEDICINE ARE ARE ALL
BECOMING CRITICAL AND IN ORDER
FOR- CALIFORNIA TO REMAIN
COMPETITIVE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO. HAVE ACCESS AND THIS I
BELIEVE WOULD BE A GOOD
INVESTMENT FOR CALIFORNIA TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT I AGREE
WITH YOU- IT'S A BIG INVESTMENT
AND WE NEED TO COMMIT TO MAKE
SURE THE PROJECTS ARE BUILT AND
THE SERVICES ARE PROVIDED.
THANK YOU INTENSIFIED GREAT
THAT THE THOSE TWO ISSUES THAT.
NOW MAY ON THE BROAD MANNER
YOUR TOP PRIORITIES BECAUSE YOU
BRING SOME FOR SOME. ODD TO THE
DISCUSSION AT YOUR OWN BOARD
I'M GOING OUT ON. COMPLETE MY
QUESTION IS WHEN I BROUGHT UP
YESTERDAY WHICH IS FEET
BASICALLY VERY DISTRICTS
SPECIFIC. AND I'M GONNA READ
THE QUESTION BECAUSE IT COMES
FROM OUR SEVERAL CONSTITUENTS
AND I THINK I SHARED WITH YOU
MAN. A COUPLE OF THE PROJECTS
THAT HAVE GONE SIDEWAYS OR
APPEAR TO HAVE GONE SIDEWAYS
FOR MUCH. MIGHT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED AND THEY ARE NOT.
ACTUALLY BUILT AND DIDN'T SEEM
TO COMPLY. WITH OF SECRET
DOCUMENTS DOCUMENTS SHOW THAT
WAS PROVIDED AND I'M I'M NOT
SURE ON EITHER ONE OF THESE ONE
IS QUITE OD AND- THERE'S SOME
CURRENT ONES AND I'M NOT SURE
WHETHER. YOU SEE. IS A
CERTIFYING- HE KNOW OF. AGENCY
FOR THE SEQUEL BUT THE QUESTION
IS WHEN APPROVING A
TRANSMISSION LINE PROJECT. WITH
CERTAIN SEQUEL REQUIREMENTS.
HOW DOES P. YOU SEE ENSURE THE
PROJECT IS BUILT TO WHAT WAS
APPROVED. AND WHAT RECOURSE OR
PROCESS TO LANDOWNERS TO
RATEPAYERS. HAVE WITH P. C. P.
YOU SEE IF THEY BELIEVE THE
PROJECT WAS BUILT OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH WHAT. ON THE
EVE SYKORA AND IF YOU SEE
ACTUALLY APPROVED. AND THOSE
ARE OUR- YOU KNOW SPECIFIC TO
PROJECTS IN THE THIRTY SIX
SENATE DISTRICT. BETTER OF A
COUPLE OF THEM ARE NOW.
BECOMING SOMEWHAT CONTROVERSY
OLD HAND I'M NOT SURE HOW TO
DIRECT MY CONSTITUENTS AWARE.
WHERE THEY FOLLOW THROUGH THEIR
COMPLAINT AND IF THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS P. YOU SEE
ON. THERE THERE ARENA OUGHT. TO
WEIGH IN WHERE DO THEY GO FROM
THERE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION- THE P. YOU SEE DOES
APPROVED CERTAIN- TRANSMISSION
POWER LINES AND SUBSTATIONS AND
IF IT IS IF YOU SEE PROJECT WE
DO HAVE- WHAT ARE CALLED
COMPLIANCE MANAGERS ARE
INVESTIGATORS THAT YOU GO OUT
AND MONITOR- WHAT'S HAPPENING
DURING CONSTRUCTION AND ALSO
REVIEW POST- CONSTRUCTION
COMPLETION OF PROJECTS IF A
PROJECT IS NOT COMPLIANT WITH
THE DECISION OR- THE
ENVIRONMENTAL. REQUIREMENTS
FROM THE C. FOR REVIEW-
CITATIONS OR PENALTIES CAN BE
ISSUED AND- I OWE YOU O BE
REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH WITHOUT
MEDICATION- IF THEY'RE NOT
DOING NOT FOR CONSTITUENTS OR
CUSTOMERS DON'T THINK IT- WE
MAY HAVE THE INFORMATION
REGARDING THE SITUATION- A
COMPLAINT CAN BE FILED FORMALLY
AND OUR- PROCESS YOUR RULES OF
PRACTICE AND PROCEDURE YOU CAN
ALSO CALL OUR STAFF IN REPORTS
ANY- NON COMPLIANCE ISSUES AND
TALK WITH OUR STAFF. THEY CAN
LET YOU KNOW IF THE PROJECT WAS
ONE THAT THAT WE SPECIFICALLY
APPROVED AND IF NOT- THE LEAD
AGENCY WOULD BE AND THEN TALK
TO YOU ABOUT ADDITIONAL REPORTS
THAT- YOU MAY HAVE EITHER
THROUGH THE P. YOU SEE OR
PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECTOR- YOU TO
THE APPROPRIATE LOCAL ENTITIES
HAVE. PERMITTED PROJECT. THANK
YOU THAT WAS VERY CLEAR AND I
WILL THAT ON THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR SPENDING TIME WITH ME
YESTERDAY AND ANSWERING ALL
THESE QUESTIONS MORE IN MORE
DETAIL TODAY I APPRECIATE THAT
THANKS AGAIN. THANK YOU SENATOR
CENTER GROVE. AND THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AT THANK YOU THANK
YOU S. DIRECTOR FOR MEETING
WITH ME YESTERDAY- I
COMMISSIONER I GUESS I SHOULD
SAY I APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH
I'M JUST GOING TO FOLLOW UP ON
A COUPLE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
I ASKED YESTERDAY- YOU KNOW- WE
TALKED ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE IN
THE PRICING FOR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY VERSES FOR UTILITIES
VERSES THE- COASTAL AREA LIKE
MY COLLEAGUE IN SANTA CRUZ- WHO
OPENS A WINDOW AT NIGHT I'M
SURE AND DOESN'T NEED AN AIR
CONDITIONER SAY WITH MY
COLLEAGUE IN LOS ANGELES SHE
SIMILAR TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AREA WHERE YOU HAVE TO HAVE AN
AIR CONDITIONER. IN OUR
DISTRICTS AND INDIVIDUAL OF OUR
STATE WHERE THE SENATE PRO TEM
REPRESENTS I DON'T THINK IT
EVER GETS OVER SEVENTY FIVE
DEGREES I COULD BE WRONG BUT-
PAGE. IMPACTED OUR A- ARE NICE
SAN DIEGO BREEZE OKAY SO AND
THE LAST FEW DAYS SPECIFICALLY
IN MY AREA IT'S BEEN A HUNDRED
AND NINE AND A HUNDRED AND TEN
DEGREES I THINK LOS ANGELES I
MAY NOT HAVE THOSE HIGH NUMBERS
BUT- IT IS SIGNIFICANTLY HOTTER
IN OUR DISTRICTS THAN IT IS-
OVER ON THE COAST. THERE WAS A
RECENTLY HELD- THE CPC RECENTLY
HELD A HEARING RECOGNIZING THE
PARTICULARLY HIGH ELECTRICITY
RATES IN CALIFORNIA AND IN FACT
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRICITY RATES
ARE DOUBLE THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE- THE WHITE PAPER FROM
THAT MEETING BASICALLY KINDA I
DON'T SEE BRUSHES IT OFF THE
BRUSHES IT OFF SAYS MOST
CALIFORNIANS ELECTRICITY BILLS
ARE RELATIVELY LOW WHICH IS
TRUE. THAT'S ON PAGE SEVEN OF
THE WHITE PAPER THAT WAS
PROVIDED AND BUT THAT'S TRUE
FOR THE COASTAL AREAS AND MAYBE
IN THE SAN DIEGO AREA BUT IT'S
NOT TRUE FOR THE MAJORITY OF
THE INDIVIDUALS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY LOS ANGELES OR THE
REGION'S. AND WHAT WOULD YOU
SAY TO CONSTITUENTS LIKE IN MY
DISTRICT OR LOS ANGELES- THAT
FACE TRIPLE DIGIT TEMPERATURES
FOR THE SUMMER MENCE THAT HAVE
EXTREMELY HIGH. UTILITY RATES I
MEAN SOME OF THEM EVEN IF YOU
KEEP YOUR AIR CONDITIONER
THEY'RE NOT ON YOU'RE NOT. ABLE
TO BE ON THE CARES PROGRAM
BECAUSE YOU'RE A WORKING
CALIFORNIAN THAT MAKES FAST
ENOUGH TO NOT BE ON THE CARES
PROGRAM. AND THESE INDIVIDUALS
MIGHT FACE EVEN KEEPING THEIR
AIR CONDITIONER EIGHTY DEGREES
A SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLAR P. GENIE
BILL OR ELECTRICITY BILL AND
WHICH IS ABOUT. PROBABLY A
THIRD OF THEIR INCOME. THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION AND AS AS
WE DISCUSSED WHEN WE MET
AFFORDABILITY IS. A CRITICAL
ISSUE THAT'S FRONT AND CENTER
AT THE COMMISSION RIGHT NOW WE-
NEED TO DO FOLLOW UP FROM OUR
END BOND WE ALSO HAVE AN OPEN
PORTABILITY PRECEDING THAT
RECENTLY ISSUED. A REPORT AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THAT
REPORT RECOGNIZES AS AS YOU'VE
INDICATED SENATOR THAT- WE NEED
TO BE LOOKING AT AFFORDABILITY
FROM A REGIONAL LEVEL AS
OPPOSED TO A STATEWIDE LEVEL
BECAUSE THERE'S DIFFERENT
INCOMES- WITHIN DIFFERENT
REGIONS AND THERE'S DIFFERENT-
CLIMATE FACTORS WITHIN THOSE
REGIONS. AND SO WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF DEVELOPING METRICS
THAT WILL HELP US BE ABLE TO
LOOK AT- AFFORDABILITY ACROSS
ALL OF OUR UTILITY SECTORS AND
LOOKING AT IT. FROM A REGIONAL
PERSPECTIVE TO ASSIST US IN
DEVELOPING BETTER PROGRAMS
LOOKING AT POSSIBLE- CHANGES TO
OUR RATE DESIGN AND HELPING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ACCOUNTING
FOR AFFORDABILITY BITE BY
HOUSEHOLD LEVEL- AS AS YOU
NOTED- OUR OUR ELECTRICITY-
HELLO
END IF YOU LOOK AT NATIONAL
AVERAGES ARE ARE BILLED AS A
STATE ARE ON THE LOWER END FOR
NATURAL THE NATIONAL AVERAGES
BUT WE SEE A TREND. THAT THOSE
RATES ARE INCREASING AND WE'RE
PARTICULARLY NOTING THAT- THERE
ARE REGIONAL. IMPACTS THAT NEED
TO BE ACCOUNTED FOR- SO WHAT
WHAT WHAT I WOULD SAY TO- THE
CONSTITUENTS FACING THOSE
ISSUES IS THAT WE DO HAVE THIS
RECEDING WE ARE LOOKING AT THIS
ISSUE. WE ARE HOPING- TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE METRICS THAT WILL
ALLOW US FOR. TWO ACCOUNTS FOR
THESE REGIONAL DIFFERENCES AND-
HOUSEHOLD INCOME FACTORS AND
THAT IT BE- NEED. CUSTOMER
PARTICIPATION MORE CONSTITUENT
PARTICIPATION AND- I ANTICIPATE
THAT WE WILL BE DOING MORE
WORKSHOPS AND OUTREACH AND-
THIS AGAIN REMAINS A ISSUE THAT
IS OF CRITICAL IMPORTANCE AND A
TOP PRIORITY FOR US AND WE
LOOKING AT IT HOW WE ASSESS
AFFORDABILITY- ON A REGIONAL
BASIS. THANK YOU MA'AM VERY
MUCH FOR THAT RESPONSE I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT- I AM
ECSTATICALLY EXCITED THAT- YOU
SEE CALIFORNIA IN DIFFERENT
REGIONS AND- HOW DIFFERENT
REGIONS CAN HAVE AS A LARGE
VARIANCE OF- I'VE UTILITY
RATES. JUST BASED ON ON THE
CLIMB INTO THE AREA OF THE
REGION IS AND SO- YOU KNOW AS
THERE'S ALWAYS FREQUENTLY ASKED
QUESTIONS REGARDING RATE REALLY
FOR RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS
THROUGH THE PROGRAMS LIKE HERE.
BUT THERE'S NOT A LOT OF RATE
RELIEF SOLUTIONS FOR INDUSTRIAL
OR AGRICULTURAL CUSTOMERS HE'S
ELECTRICITY RATES ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER. THAN
COMPETITORS IN NEIGHBORING
STATES. THE REASON WHY I ASK
THAT IS. IN MY DISTRICT WE HAVE
THE LARGEST A- TAITO PRODUCER I
GUESS ANY FINGERLING MANY
POTATO. PURPLE POTATO YELLOW
POTATO THOSE LITTLE MINI ROUND
ONES THAT YOU BUY AT COSTCO OR
WALMART OR- I HAVE BONDS I MEAN
THEY'RE SOLD EVERYWHERE SO
FINGERLINGS THAT'S A SPECIALTY
AS WELL- TO REFRIGERATE THEM IT
THE RATES- HAVE ALMOST
QUADRUPLED IN THE LAST YEAR FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO
REFRIGERATED. THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT MOVING TO ARIZONA. JUST A
WAREHOUSE OR STUFF BECAUSE IT
WOULD BE CHEAPER TO TRANSPORT
THEM VIA TRACK. YOU KNOW ACROSS
STATE LINES WHERE THEY NEEDED
TO BE DISTRIBUTED THEN IT WOULD
BE T. PAY UTILITY RATES- ALSO-
YOU LARGEST BABY CARE PRODUCER
IN THE WORLD IS IN MY
DISTRACTION TO MY COLLEAGUE MR
TUDOSE DISTRICT BUT IN KERN
COUNTY. AND THEY HIS SIT FACE
THE SIMILAR SITUATION- THEY'VE
ACTUALLY STARTED PURCHASING
LANDIN AND PROPERTY IN
GEORGIA. WE HATE TO LOSE THOSE
BUSINESSES- BUT ONE OF THE MAIN
FACTORS THAT THEY'VE DECIDED.
IS UTILITY RATES- FOR
REFRIGERATING THESE PRODUCTS
WHETHER IT'S POTATOES CARROTS
PLUMS APPLES DOESN'T MATTER.
AND THE UTILITY RATES IS THERE
A SOLUTION THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE
REGARDING THE ECONOMIC BURDENS
THAT THE STATE'S BUSINESSES AND
FARMS FACE BECAUSE OF THE HIGH
UTILITY. RATES- ELECTRICITY
RATES. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION- SENATOR AYE AGAIN A
PORTABILITY- IS VERY IMPORTANT-
TO THE PC AND WE ARE. LOOKING
AT DIFFERENT WAYS TO- ANALYZE
FORTY BOARD ABILITY FOR
DIFFERENT FOR DIFFERENT SECTORS
OF- BOTH THE ECONOMY AND-
CUSTOMER BASE I DO NOT HAVE. A
SPECIFIC ANSWER REGARDING A
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE- THAT MAY
BE GEARED SPECIFICALLY TOWARDS
AGRICULTURE BUT- I CAN FOLLOW
UP WITH YOUR OFFICE AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION IF YOU
WOULD ALLOW ME TO DO THAT. I
WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU. THE LAST QUESTION I
HAVE IS- I'M SURE IT'S ALL ON
OUR MIND BECAUSE THE COLONIAL
HACK RIGHT AND- WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT YESTERDAY
THE COLONIAL PIPELINE HACKEN
AND I THINK ONE OF THE BIGGEST
THREATS THAT WE FACE IN THEM
ARE UTILITIES. IS OUR ENERGY IS
THE ENERGY GET ITSELF- AND THE
POTENTIAL EXPOSURE THAT WE HAVE
FOR HACKING THE ENERGY GRID AND
SHUTTING DOWN AND THE STATE'S
POWER. AS WE TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT NEW TECHNOLOGY THERE IS A
COMPANY IN- THE SENATE PROTEAMS
DISTRICT ACTUALLY AND I THINK
SHE KNOWS ONE OF THE
PRINCIPLES- FROM A PREVIOUS I
SEE PREVIOUS LIFE I THINK IT'S
WHEN SHE'S ON THE CITY COUNCIL.
THE M. AS THE EQUITY TECH- HAS
ACTUALLY DEVELOPED A TECHNOLOGY
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S
BEING USED ON THEM. AT THE
SADDLE. PG&E IS IT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON SOUTHERTON
THE TEST ACTUALLY THE TEST WAS
DEAD. WE SAN DIEGO AT SDG ANNIE
SO SAN DIEGO GAS AND- IN WHAT
IS IT ESTEY GENE. IT IS ESTY
GENIE AND ACTUALLY THEY WERE
THE ONES THAT PROVE THE MODEL.
IT THAT ALLOWS- THAT PREVENTS-
99% OF THE- THE HACKING I GUESS
OR THE PENETRATION THAT WOULD
TAKE PLACE- I AGAINST OUR
UTILITY GRID. ARE YOU GOING TO
PURSUE- JUST BECAUSE WE ALL
AGREE THAT WE NEED SAFE
RELIABLE DEPENDABLE ENERGY
PEOPLE WANT TO FLIP THE SWITCH
AND HAVE THE LIGHTS COME ON.
AND WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO
PURSUER AT LEAST HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THOSE PEOPLE
THAT WE PROTECT TO LOOK TO
LISTEN TO THEIR TECHNOLOGY TO
SEE IF IT WOULD BE BENEFICIAL
TO ALL OF CALIFORNIANS. I'M NOT
PUSHING A CERTAIN COMPANY I'M
MISSING IT'S AVAILABLE HERE
WOULD YOU BE INTERESTED. IN YES
I WOULD BE INTERESTED AYE I
KNOW THIS IS AN- IMPORTANT
ISSUE ESPECIALLY GIVEN. THE
SITUATION BACK EAST WITH THE
COLONIAL PIPELINE SO- ANY
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON HOW
WE CAN PROTECT OUR- ELECTRIC
SYSTEM I WOULD I WOULD BE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I GUESS
THE LAST QUESTION I THOUGHT
THAT WAS MY LAST BUT I
REMEMBERED YESTERDAY THAT WE
TALK SIGNIFICANTLY. ABOUT THE
PS PS I SHUT OFFS- YOU KNOW
DURING THAT SHOWED US LAST
YEAR- THE CITY OF TEHACHAPI IN
MY DISTRICT AND OTHER CITIES-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- WERE
NOTIFIED. BY THE CPUC OR THE
ELECTRICAL PROVIDERS THE
PROVIDERS. THAT AND THEY WOULD
BE EXPERIENCING THE SHUT OFF
DUE TO HIGH WINDS OR WINDS AND
TO PREVENT WILDFIRES. AS
SOMETIMES- THERE WAS EITHER
ZERO COMMUNICATION OR WAS
INCORRECT OR INACCURATE
COMMUNICATION SIGNIFICANTLY
INTACT BEAM. THEY WERE TOLD A
LINE B. OR LINE A WOULD BE SHUT
DOWN AND THEY PREPARED FOR THAT
AND WAS THE ALTERNATE LINE THAT
WE SHUT DOWN WHICH AFFECTED
THEIR WASTEWATER TREATMENT
PLANT. AND THE HOSPITAL AND
SOME OTHER THINGS HAD TO GO ON
BACK UP POWER WHICH THEY WERE
NOT PREPARED FOR BECAUSE WHAT
THEY WERE NOTIFIED WAS THE
OPPOSITE LINE. AND WHAT'S YOUR
THOUGHTS ABOUT GETTING AND
BETTER COMMUNICATION. AND FOR
THESE P. S. P. S. AT. ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE. THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION AND THAT THE P.
YOU SEE RECENTLY ADOPTED- A
DECISION AND AN ORDER
INSTITUTING AN INVESTIGATION ON
SOME OF THE TWENTY NINETEEN PS
PS EVENTS WHERE WE FOUND THAT-
THE UTILITIES NEEDED TO IMPROVE
THEIR COMMUNICATION AND- TEACH
WHAT HAD HAPPENED PREVIOUSLY WE
ALSO HAVE ANOTHER DECISION-
REGARDING PS PS GUIDELINES THAT
ARE BEING UPDATED THAT WILL BE
VOTED OUT TOMORROW IN OUR OUR
BUDDY. AND MANY OF THE ISSUES
YOU TALKED ABOUT REGARDING
COMMUNICATION AND NOTICE WERE
FRONT AND CENTER- IN REGARDS TO
THE REVISIONS ON THE TRIP- ON
THE GUIDELINES AND- IT LOOKS
THAT YOU KNOW INFORMATION
REGARDING CRITICAL FACILITIES
AND INFRASTRUCTURE- THE MINIMUM
SERVICES THAT ARE GOING TO NEED
TO BE PROVIDED DURING YES YES
ADVANCE- IT REQUIRES EXERCISES-
TO WORK BURKE. AT LEAST
ANNUALLY AND THAT- THAT THERE'S
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH- AND
COMMUNICATION WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND- WE I ASKED IN
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND ENTITIES ON
AN ONGOING BASIS SO THAT- WE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
GETTING THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED. TIME TO PREPARE FOR THESE
EVENTS TO STAY SAFE AND TO
ENSURE THAT- PARTICULARLY OUR
MEDICAL BASELINE CUSTOMERS- ARE
ABLE TO GET WHAT THEY NEED TO
GET THROUGH- THE EVENTS AND
NOTIFICATION. ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL- TO THIS EFFORTS AND-
WE WILL BE WORKING WITH THE I.
O. U.'S AND THE DIFFERENT
ENTITIES AND PARTICIPATING IN
THESE EXERCISES- WE ENCOURAGE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND ENTITIES
TO LET US KNOW IS THEY'RE
HAVING PROBLEMS. SO THAT WE CAN
ALSO- CONTINUE TO TRACK IT- AS
WE'RE DEVELOPING PROCESSES
HERE- I DON'T THINK. IF WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE EVENTS
WERE GOING TO BE ABLE TO SAY
THAT THAT THEIR NEW MUCH LONGER
AND- WE'RE GONNA NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT NOTIFICATIONS
OCCURRING SOUNDS THAT- PEOPLE
ARE BEING KEPT SAFE DURING.
THESE EVENTS. ESPECIALLY GIVEN
THE WHOLE PURPOSE IS TO PREVENT
OTHER- IT'S PAST REVIEWS FROM
NOT HAPPENING SO- WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE BEING
HANDLED SAFELY XBOX. THANK YOU
MA'AM THANK YOU FOR ANSWERING
MY QUESTIONS AND FOR MEETING
WITH ME YESTERDAY I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE IT AND THEM. I LOOK
FORWARD TO OF A CONFIRMING YOU
ON THIS CONFIRMATION AND DEM. I
THINK YESTERDAY THE FIRST
QUESTION I ASKED YOU IS WHY. DO
YOU WANT TO DO THIS JOB AND-
EVERYBODY ON THE CALL KINDA
LAUGHED AND YOU SAID YOU GET
ASKED THAT QUESTION A LOT. AND
EVERYBODY SEEMS TO LAUGH
AFTERWARDS ALTHOUGH I TRIED TO
ASK IT VERY SERIOUSLY- I
APPRECIATE YOU WANTING TO DO
THIS JOB. SO THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU SENATOR I. THAT THAT
WAS A THAT WAS A VERY RELEVANT
LAST QUESTION I'M THINKING
ABOUT I THINK I MIGHT IS SAID
TO THE SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES
THIS IS A SERIOUS JOB. I'M NOT
SURE SHE GETS ENOUGH
COMPENSATION BUT- AT ANY RATE-
THAT'S A DIFFERENT QUESTION AND
NOT WANT TO POSE TO YOU
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO. COMMENT ON
TO THE BUDGET PROCESS- TO THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES
SENATOR COM LOCKER. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- AND I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM KERN
WHO ASKED A NUMBER OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT- I THINK I ASKED
YOU AND WE DISCUSSED EARLIER
THIS DAY AT TODAY ESPECIALLY
AROUND THE RATE AFFORDABILITY.
AND I TO ASK YOU KNOW WHY YOU
WANT TO DO THIS BECAUSE IT
SEEMS LIKE THE UC IS JUST HUGE
AND COVERS SO MANY THINGS THAT
ARE. INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT NEAR
CRITICAL AN- ALMOST SEEMS LIKE
THEY SHOULD SORT OF BEING
CHUCKED OUT- AND HANDLED.
INDEPENDENTLY SO. BLESS YOU ALL
FOR THE KIND OF MENTAL STAMINA
THAT YOU HAVE FOR WANTING TO DO
THIS WORK. FROM I ASKED YOU
EARLIER AND SO I'LL ASK YOU
AGAIN I HAD A QUESTION ABOUT
LIFELINE- WHICH IS A PROGRAM
THAT PROVIDES FREE OR
DISCOUNTED TELEPHONE SERVICE TO
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND YOU
SHARED WITH ME THE INTRICACIES-
IN THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
FEDS. AND THE STATE AS IT
RELATES TO LIFELINE NO DURING
THE PANDEMIC LAST YEAR THERE
WERE SOME CHANGES THAT WERE
MADE- I BELIEVE TO- AND IN
ORDER TO INCREASE ENROLLMENT OR
RE ENROLLMENT AND TO MAKE
THINGS A LITTLE MORE USER
FRIENDLY FOR FOLKS. SO IT IS
ALWAYS INTERESTING THE LESSONS
THAT WE LEARN IN TIMES OF
CRISIS ON HOW TO MAKE THINGS
MORE USER FRIENDLY FOR FOLKS-
AND WANTED TO KNOW IF YOU COULD
SHARE A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT.
THE C. P. UC'S RE VISIONING OF
LIFELINE- NOW- AND HOW WE ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO STREAMLINE
THIS PROCESS SEES. A TO MAKE
THIS- PROGRAM. MORE ACCESSIBLE
TO FOLKS WHO NEED IT- AND THEN
ALSO GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE ARE
OPERATING IN A MORE AND MORE
WITH OUR LAN LINES- BUT WITH
MOBILE DEVICES AND SMARTPHONES.
AND I KNOW LIFELINE IS I THINK
ONE PER HOUSEHOLD. RATHER THAN
ONE PER PHONE I'M EVEN THE MOST
OF US ARE ATTACHED TO THE PHONE
AND- IT HAS BECOME MY LIFELINE
AND NO PUN INTENDED SO. JUST
WANTED TO KNOW IF YOU COULD
SHARE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW-
SOME OF THIS REVISION NG-
EITHER IS HAPPENING OR OTHER.
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT OTHER THINGS
IN THE WORKS- THAT COULD MAKE
THIS PROGRAM. MORE ACCESSIBLE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
AND- WE DO HAVE A CURRENT OPEN
PROCEEDING ON LIFELINE ONE OF
THAT- THE- ITEMS IN THAT
PROCEEDING IS THAT WE ARE
PARTNERING WITH SAC STATE TO
ASSESS THE PROGRAM AND EXAMINE
WHAT- THE BARRIERS ARE TO
PARTICIPATION. AND THE CUSTOMER
NEEDS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THAT REPORT COMING
OUT HOPEFULLY VERY SOON AS SOON
AS IT DOES WE WILL BE ABLE TO
SHARE IT WITH YOUR OFFICE- THE
CURRENT. PROCEEDING RIGHT NOW
IS LOOKING AT UPDATES TO
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE RULES TO
IMPROVE THE PROGRAM WHICH WILL
BE LOOKING AT THIS REPORT THAT
WERE WORKING SAC STATE ON- TO
UPDATE THE PROGRAM TO ADDRESS-
CHANGES THAT HAVE OCCURRED TO
STATE AND FEDERAL POLICIES AND
NEW TECHNOLOGIES. AS WELL AS
UNRESOLVED ISSUES FROM PREVIOUS
PROCEEDINGS AND YOU YOU ARE
CORRECT SENATOR AT THE MOMENT-
IT IS ONE- DEVICE PER HOUSEHOLD
SO IT WOULD EITHER BE A
LANDLINE OR A- A MOBILE OF A
PHONE- WE ALSO- RECENTLY HAD
UPDATED B. THE PROGRAM SHE
REQUIRE WIRELESS RESERVE
PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE LIFELINE
PLANS- AT NO COST TO
PARTICIPANTS HOWEVER- I DO WANT
TO KNOW THE DOT- ISSUE IS IN
LITIGATION RIGHT NOW- THE COURT
THE FEDERAL COURT HAD OVER
TRYING TO THAT AND- IT IS ON
IT. HE ALSO WE CAN ALSO FOLLOW
UP AS WE HAVE MORE INFORMATION-
REGARDING THAT AND THEN WHEN WE
SPOKE I ALSO MENTIONED ARE AYE
FOSTER PILOT PROGRAM WHICH IS
TARGETED TO MEET THE NEEDS OF-
OF THE- FOSTER CHILDREN IN THE
STATE AND RIGHT NOW IT SERVES
ABOUT ELEVEN THOUSAND FOSTER
YOUTH BETWEEN THE AGES OF
THIRTEEN AND THIRTY SIX AND
FIFTY SIX. OF FIFTY EIGHT- SO
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THAT WE
ARE ACTIVELY LOOKING OUT AND
WE'RE HOPING THAT- WITH THIS
STUDY IN OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH
SAC STATE WILL BE ABLE TO COME
UP WITH SOME RECOMMENDATIONS
VERY SEEN. ON I WENT THROUGH
THE PROGRAM. GREAT THANK YOU-
BECAUSE I YOU KNOW I THINK. I
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE
LAND LINES- NOT THAT MANY AND
THEN THE ONES THAT DO PROBABLY
DON'T REALLY EVEN KNOW WHAT THE
JACK IS- AND SO I THINK IT'S
WORK YOU KNOW CONTINUING TO
MOVE INTO- YOU KNOW THE REST OF
THIS CENTURY AND BEYOND. YOU
KNOW HOW WE CAN FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO ALLOW FOR CONNECTIVITY
TO BE EASIER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO MANAGE IS
REALLY IMPORTANT REGARDLESS OF
THEIR INCOME. I'M I KNOW THE
VICE CHAIR ASKED A QUESTION
ABOUT BROADBAND- AND SO I TO
WILL- AND I KNOW WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIS- I THINK
BASED ON. WELL WE'VE ALL SEEN
THE PHOTOS OF THE YOUNG BABIES
WHO ARE SITTING OUTSIDE OF TACO
BELL- TRYING TO DO THEIR
HOMEWORK I THINK WE HAVE ALL
HAD AN INSTANCE WHERE THE PHONE
CALL HAS DROPPED- WE ARE
WALKING AROUND THE BLOCK TRYING
TO FIND A PLACE WHERE WE'RE
GETTING A GOOD SIGNAL- AND I
THINK. EVERYONE AT ONE POINT-
HAS YELLED OUT BROADBAND FOR
ALL- OUT OF FRUSTRATION OF
HAVING YOU KNOW THE PHONE OR
THE ZOOM- DROP THE CALL OR OR-
STALL OUT. ACCORDING TO THE
DATA ON YOUR WEBSITE THERE ARE
SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS
THAT DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
BROADBAND- WITH STANDARD
DOWNLOAD SPEEDS- AND MILLIONS
OF STUDENTS WHO HAVE STRUGGLED
ACROSS THE VIRTUAL SCHOOL YEAR.
I'M IN THE HOUSEHOLDS THAT
DON'T HAVE IT OR SPLIT BETWEEN
RURAL AND URBAN. AND WE HEAR
THE CRIES FOR HELP AND SUPPORT.
REALLY FOR MOST OF THE FOLKS ON
THE FLOOR WHEN WE ACTUALLY WHEN
WE HAVE BILLS THAT COME UP
AROUND BROADBAND- AND SO YOU
KNOW WE WANTED TO KNOW WHAT THE
PLAN WAS FOR CREATING
CONNECTIVITY- FOR EACH OF THESE.
HOUSEHOLDS AND IF SO IF THERE
ARE BENCHMARKS PLATE HOW TO
REACH X. NUMBER BY X. YEAR- AND
THEN ALSO WANTED TO KNOW- WHAT
THE P. YOU SEE YOU CAN DO- TO
PREVENT INCUMBENT- PROVIDERS-
FROM. THE USE THE OVER USE THE
ABUSE YOU CAN USE THE VERB THAT
YOU WANT- RIGHT OF FIRST
REFUSAL BECAUSE MANY
COMMUNITIES BELIEVE- THAT THIS
IS GREATLY DELAYED THERE C. A.
S. FUNDED PROJECTS I KNOW I
ASKED YOU THIS WHEN WE SPOKE
EARLIER. IN THIS ACTUALLY CAME
UP AS A POINT OF DISCUSSION
WHEN WE HAD ONE OF OUR
BROADBAND BILLS UP ON THE
SENATE FLOOR- AND SO WANTED TO
JUST GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT
BECAUSE I DOUBT THAT WE ARE
GOING TO RESOLVE THIS. THIS
YEAR- AND IT'S A IT'S A MATTER
OF THE KIND OF LONG TERM
COMMITMENT WE CAN MAKE- NOT
ONLY TO OUR INFRASTRUCTURE. BUT
INTO MANAGING THE RELATIONSHIPS
OF ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT
ARE INVOLVED. IN THE ISSUE
AROUND PROVIDING BROADBAND
NETWORKS ROUGHLY. ONE THANK YOU
SENATOR AND AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE OF BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE IS A- TOP
PRIORITY FOR ME AND THE P. YOU
SEE I THINK THAT THE CURRENT
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD HAVE- THE
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
REFERENCED EARLIER. INVESTED
INTO- THIS INFRASTRUCTURE WILL
GO A LONG WAY- IF WE CAN GET A
SYSTEM THAT IS. OPEN ACCESS AND
HAS A NETWORK THAT BASICALLY
WILL ALLOW FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TRIBAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND- NETWORK
PROVIDERS- TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT- FAIR MARKET RATES- IT
WILL GO A LONG WAY TO FILLING
THESE GAPS AND HELPING TO
IMPROVE OUR CONNECTIVITY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- I THINK
COMING OUT OF THE PANDEMIC. WE
REALLY SEE THE NEED- FOR
INVESTING IN THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE IT ACCESSIBLE SO I
THINK OPEN ACCESS IS GOING TO
BE IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
CRITICAL TO DOT. AND THIS IS
GOING TO INVOLVE ON
DISCUSSIONS. WITH A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT AGENCIES- LOOKING AT
THE LEGISLATION THAT IS PENDING
AS WELL AS- THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS THEY HAVE- BUT
THE WORK CERTAIN STORIES OVER
BROADBAND AS WELL SO. I THINK
WE ARE AT- HEY GOOD POINT
COMING OUT OF THE PANDEMIC OF
THE PUBLIC- REALLY
UNDERSTANDING THE NEED TO HAVE
BROADBAND FOR US TO CONTINUE-
TO HAVE- YOU KNOW WE WE'RE THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD AND WE NEED TO MAINTAIN-
TECHNOLOGY AND ACCESS FOR
CALIFORNIANS- TO THE INTERNET.
TO ENSURE WE- CAN CONTINUE WITH
OUR ECONOMY NEEDS YOU- AND SURE
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO
EDUCATION- TELEMEDICINE
ESPECIALLY FOR RURAL AREAS IS-
CRITICAL SO AS I SAID BEFORE
YOU CAN FIT INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY IS MORE THAN A
LUXURY IT'S BECOMING A NEED
ESPECIALLY- GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THIS LAST YEAR
SO I THINK- GETTING THESE
MIDDLE MILE GAPS IN THESE LAST
MILE STILL AND PROVIDING OPEN
ACCESS. WILL GO A LONG WAY I
DON'T THINK IT WILL BE EASY AND
I THINK- IT'S GOING TO BE
CHALLENGING BUT I AM HOPING
THAT- THE PC WILL BE ABLE TO
MAKE IT THE DIFFERENCE IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE OTHER
AGENCIES THAT HELP
RESPONSIBILITY HERE AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO. YOU- THE CASF
PROGRAM- MOVING FORWARD WITH
THE NEXT STAGE. YEAH SO IS IT-
IN THE END YOU DO NOT HAVE THE
MAGIC WAND OR THE CRYSTAL BALL-
HELLO I AM GOOD I'M PUTTING
THAT OUT THERE FOR ALL TO NOTE
TO ALL FOR ALL TO HEAR- BUT
WHAT IS IT FAIR TO SAY THAT WE
DON'T QUITE HAVE. A PLAN WITH
REAL NUMBERS ARE BENCHMARKS- ON
HOW TO GET CONNECTIVITY TO THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF FOLKS
THAT DON'T YET HAVE IT THAT WE
MAY BE WORKING ON IT BUT WITH
AS OF TODAY WORDS WE MAY NOT BE
THERE YET. I THINK THAT'S FAIR
TO SAY THAT WE ARE WORKING ON
IT- WE- ARE LOOKING TO SEE-
WHAT. THE CASF PROGRAM IS GONNA
LOOK LIKE GOING FORWARD IF YOU
YOU KNOW THE CURRENT PROPOSED
PROPOSAL ALSO TALKS ABOUT
DOING- RNP IS AS OPPOSED TO
APPLICATIONS AND HOPEFULLY THAT
WILL HELP- GET. MORE PROVIDERS
AND APPLICATIONS IN THE DORK-
AND THE GOAL IS TO GET- YOU
KNOW THAT THE FIBER IN THE
GROUND TO GET THINGS MOVING BUT
I CAN'T GIVE YOU AN EXACT DATES
OR TIMEFRAMES- THERE'S STILL A
LOT OF QUESTIONS OUT THERE AS
FAR AS WHAT THE PARAMETERS WILL
BE THAT WILL HAVE TO WORK WITH
AND- FORWARD. YEAH THAT THAT'S
WHY I PREFACED WHAT I SAID WITH
YOU NOT HAVING A MAGIC WAND I
DIDN'T WANT YOU TO THINK THAT.
THAT WAS ALL LIES ON YOU- YOU
DID MENTION LOOKING AT
LEGISLATION- WORKING WITH THE
FEDS AND THEN BRINGING OTHER
AGENCIES TO THE TABLE I WOULD
JUST ALSO ENCOURAGE- THAT WE-
CONSIDER HOW TO BRING OUR-
TELECOM PROVIDERS TO THE TABLE
TO BECAUSE THEY ARE ENDING I
MEAN THEY'RE CRITICAL TO THIS
DISCUSSION- AND- THE REALITY IS
THAT MOST CALIFORNIANS DON'T
REALLY KNOW WHAT THE P. YOU SEE
DOES. AND THERE THEY DON'T HAVE
THIS VERY INTRICATE WEB OF
AGENCIES AND CONNECTIONS THAT
WE MAY HAVE OR KNOW ABOUT WHEN
THEY'RE THINKING ABOUT HOW COME
THEY CAN'T MAKE A CALL- AND BUT
WHAT THEY DO NOW- ARE LIKE THE
NAMES OF THE- THINGS THAT COME
TO THEM IN THE MAIL EACH MONTH
ASKING THEM FOR PAYMENT. AND
WHAT THEY DO NOW IS THE DEVICE
THAT THEY HAVE. AND WHETHER OR
NOT IT'S WORKING OR NOT AND SO
IT REALLY IS INCUMBENT UPON
GOVERNMENT- AND WE ARE PART OF
GOVERNMENT- THE LEGISLATURE. TO
FIGURE OUT WAYS TO HELP
TRANSLATE ALL OF THESE
PROBLEMS- IN ISSUES INTO
SOMETHING THAT THAT FOLKS CAN
UNDERSTAND- BUT THEN ALSO TO
HELP CREATE SOLUTIONS AND
PATHWAYS. THAT MAKE EQUAL
SENSE- AND SO I SAY THAT
BECAUSE- WHILE SOMETIMES THERE
MAY BE TENSION. BETWEEN ALL OF
THE PARTIES WE REALLY HAVE AN
OBLIGATION AND A RESPONSIBILITY
TO WORK TOGETHER- BECAUSE-
CONNECTIVITY IS. PART OF LIFE
NOW I MEAN YOU WE'VE BECOME
CODES AND DEVICES- IN ALL OF
THIS AND SO. BEING THAT WE'RE
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD I'M THE RICHEST IN
THE ASSETS THAT WE HAVE WE
REALLY HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT.
YOU KNOW FROM SAN DIEGO TO Y.
RICA- WE ARE FIGURING OUT WAYS
TO CONNECT EVERYBODY- TO THE
SERVICES AND TO THE PEOPLE ON
THE DAY THEY SHOULD BE ALLOWED
TO BE CONNECTED TO- SO THAT'S
ALL I'M GONNA SAY I THINK YOU-
GOOD LUCK SISTER. I MEAN YOU'RE
GONNA NEED IT- AND I HOPE YOU
CONSIDER YOU KNOW US PARTNERS-
EVEN WHEN WE'RE UPSET BECAUSE I
THINK WE'RE REALLY ALL WORKING
TOWARDS THE SAME GOAL. THANK
YOU SENATOR WELL ON A LOT OF
TOPICS COVERED OUR I CHECKED
HIM OFFICE AS PEOPLE WERE GOING
DOWN THE LIST AND MAKE IT
PRETTY MUCH COVERED ABOUT
EVERY. QUESTION THAT I COULD
HAVE ALSO BROUGHT UP I WOULD- I
WOULD SAY THE ISSUE OF US
CYBERSECURITY IS BECOMING MORE
OF A CONCERN FROM SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE CAUCUS AND-
I'M GLAD OF THAT QUESTION WAS
ASKED BECAUSE ON JUST FROM A
GENERAL STANDPOINT. WANTING TO
MAKE SURE THAT- YOU KNOW IT'S
SERIOUSLY ON THE C. P. U. C.
OUR RADAR SCREEN AND ON YOURS.
I'LL JUST ADD THAT I. I
COULDN'T AGREE MORE. I KNOW
THAT YOU WERE APPOINTED IN
FEBRUARY BUT I GIVEN YOUR YOUR
HISTORY YOUR BACKGROUND AND
YOUR RESUME I KNOW THAT YOU HIT
THE GROUND RUNNING. ON ALL
THESE ISSUES- THESE ARE COMPLEX
ISSUES AS- SENATOR COM LONGER
SAID- YOU KNOW THERE'S JUST SO
MANY DIFFERENT AREAS THAT YOU
HAVE TO BE. A FAMILIAR WITH SO%
I FEEL LIKE YOU OBVIOUSLY MUST
LOVE THE WORK ODD TO ACCEPT THE
APPOINTMENT AND DO THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING SO I THANK YOU FOR
THAT. WITH THAT- COMMISSIONER
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD NOW AND
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY. AND
LET ME GO AHEAD AND DO A
REMINDER FOR WITNESSES WISHING
TO PROVIDE COMMENT VIA PHONE.
THAT WE HAVE A PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER. WHICH IS.
877-692-8958 IT'S ON THE
SCREEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
NINE EIGHT TWO NINE TWO ZERO
NINE. AND WITH THAT WE'RE GOING
TO START IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. I ACTUALLY DO NOT SEE
ANYONE HERE ALL IN PERSON I'M A
LOOK AT ROOM ONE TWELVE R.
SPILLOVER ROOM. AND GIVEN THAT
THERE'S NO ONE IN HERE I ALSO
SEE THAT THERE IS NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. SO ODD MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU'VE BEEN
HANGING OUT LISTENING AND WITH
US I WANT TO WELCOME YOU BACK.
AND ASK YOU TO. Q. EVERYONE UP.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO IN THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE. ZERO. ADELINE TWENTY NINE
YEAR MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THE TECHNICALITY
HAPPENED A CALIFORNIA IF IT
SHOULD BE AND DEMAND MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROJECT THANK YOU. AN ALIGNMENT.
THIRTY TWO. HI THIS IS EILEEN
TABLET THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION
ELECTRIFICATION CAN COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION I'M
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF DARCY
HOW CAN BE COMMISSIONER AT THE
CALIFORNIA. PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION I WOULD SAY AFTER
WORKING WITH HER FOR MORE THAN
A DECADE ON TRIBAL AND OTHER
VERY VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES AND
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE LARGELY
OVERLOOKED. HER COMMITMENT TO
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WILL BE A HUGE ASSET TO THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION AND
AGAIN STRONG BECAUSE ON THE
APPOINTMENT OF DIRTY HAWK.
COMMISSIONER TO THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALAINA. THIRTY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON
MEMBERS- PATRICK WHELAN ELSE
WILL SNAP YOU SEE HERE ON
BEHALF OF CASE WE ARE THE
SCHOOLS OF REPRESENTATIVE FOR
BARGAINING UNIT TO WE REPRESENT
ALL OF THE STATE'S ATTORNEYS
AND JUDGES INCLUDING ABOUT A
HUNDRED FIFTY ATTORNEYS JUDGES
AT UC AND NOT ONLY IS- IS HOW
FORMER MEMBER I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF KNOWING HER
PERSONALLY AND I CAN ASSURE
YOU- YOU COULDN'T ASK FOR A
MORE EXPERIENCED INTELLIGENT
AND PASSIONATE- NOMINEE AND ICE
PROBABLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK THANK YOU. AN ONLINE
TWENTY TWO. HELLO THIS IS JENNY
GANYAN I'M THE GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR THE BLUE
LAKE RANCHERIA WHICH IS THE
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA- I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH
DOROTHY- FOR ALMOST A DECADE
NOW AND I JUST WANT TO GO-
OTHERS COMMENT AND WE WANTED TO
CALL AND- TO REGISTER OUR
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALAINA. THIRTY HELLO
THIS IS MARK TONY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF TURN THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF COMMISSIONER
HOW CONFIRMATION BECAUSE OF HER
LEADERSHIP HER EXPERIENCE AND
HER LIFELONG COMMITMENT TO
PUBLIC SERVICE. AND YOU CAN
COUNT ON TURN TO DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO HOLD HER TO ALL THE
PROMISES AND COMMITMENTS SHE
MADE TODAY IN FRONT OF
COMMITTEES. THANK YOU. A LINE.
TWENTY MEMBERS ENTERING
ABSOLUTE HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY. THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE THANK. THANK
YOU. WHY WELL. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS PILOT TRITON
TRANSGRESSED HOPING ON BEHALF
OF BRIAN MENTAL DEFENSE FUND
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF MR HOUSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND MADAM
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU SHORTLY- WE WILL NOW I
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM OUR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT WE
WILL TURN TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT- MAY WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. SO I WILL START
BACK HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE AND AGAIN I YOU SEE
YOU KNOW MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE AT THE MOMENT. SO CHECK IN
QUICKLY ROOM ONE TWELVE. NO ONE
ARE THERE SO MISTER MODERATOR
I'M COMING BACK TO YOU NOW FOR
ANYONE THAT MIGHT BE IN
OPPOSITION WHO IS READY TO
SPEAK. FOR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AND NECROMANTIC AND
ONE BENVIE ROAD. AND I SHOW NO
COMMENT COMING THROUGH AT THE
TIME. MISTER MODERATOR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR HELP AND
ASSISTANCE TODAY WE DO
APPRECIATE IT. OKAY I WELCOME
THANK YOU OUT WILL NOW BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK I TO THE
MEMBERS ARE THINKING OF COURSE
THE FOLKS WHO CALLED IN
SUPPORT- WHO MOVED. THANK YOU
SO IF YOU MISS CALM WATER RIGHT
WELL THAT WAS MISS GROWTH SORRY.
I'M USED TO TURN IN MY EAR
TOWARDS THAT SIDE OF THE ROOM
SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
GROWTH MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROWTH
AYE GROVE AYE LAGER AYE AND
LONGER HIGH LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES RIGHT IT'S AYE ATKINS
FIVE FIVE FIVE THAT WAS
UNANIMOUS WE WILL MOVE THIS ON
TO THE SENATE FOR COPPER FULL
CONFIRMATION SO CONGRATULATIONS
AND THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR TIME
TODAY COMMISSIONER. OKAY I THIS
CONCLUDES TODAY'S PUBLIC
PORTION OF THE AGENDA SO I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY. IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY. TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS. WE
ARE VALUE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS THAT THEY ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE THIS TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. SO I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION AGAIN
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES
ONE NOW MOVES TO EXECUTIVE
SESSION.